[Music]
time is 13 o'clock
[Music]
all right welcome back to the show what
is today Janet it's the Valentine's Day
special Valentine's Day we're doing
Valentine's Day [ __ ] all this week yeah
you know what we do every year
Valentine's rolls around it's always
like a killer couples yeah this is I
believe this is volume three yeah of
killer couples I had to go back to the
like the last two shows cuz I couldn't
remember like what once we had done
before and I don't want to like repeat
them yeah it was over the years I guess
we've just done so much material we
forget what was on the show what was
knowledge I know I have to like go back
and check yeah because yeah so I've had
actual subscribers come ask me questions
about shows happen like three years ago
I remember the show they're talking
about wait till we do is air on that
yeah it's cool because like new people
are finding us all the time but it's
like you know with you know this right
here is episode 182 and we've done so
many fit and some of those episodes had
like more than one story on it like some
of the disappearances cases and like the
killer couples cases so it's like and I
don't so I don't remember like
everything that we did yeah if we did
the show like a year ago do some [ __ ] we
did the audio was so life I solo five
it's almost kind of like we forgot about
this shows yeah probably because
reversed for a long time we didn't even
have a video coming I just had like
swirling like a scrolling slide shows
which is pain in the ass it was we're
still trying to figure out lighting we
got a decent camera but if we put it on
on HD the computer systems we have
wouldn't be yeah my computer guys take
forever
no yeah then like the audio and the
video starts going I think it does that
if um now every now and then like
especially if we record for too long
like at a go that's why usually I see
these in pieces because if I go like
more over like if I go like more than an
hour and 15 minutes in one shot yeah
it'll start the audio in the video will
start going out of thing yeah because
you know we will improve the show is
just gonna have to happen slowly and
when we get more patrons you know which
we could always use more patrons you
know we have a small hardcore patron
following you know I mean like we got a
lot of 20 $20 a month plus subscribe
there's not a whole lot of them so we're
at the point now where if you want to
become a subscriber and you only want to
excuse me if you want to become a patron
on patreon every dollar would now help
at this point
well yeah if we had like 300 people each
given like a dollar that would make a
big difference well yeah definitely
I could definitely like um you know
upgrade equipment do that better cameras
yeah cuz I mean you know I do have one
by foot by but my Mac is still like
several years old so I kind of like
switch back and forth from like the PC
because one of our listeners sent me a
free PC and yeah it's like really Oh
super I wasn't big up so I've been using
that for um for video editing but I
still record on the Mac yeah so and the
Mac is still several years me that's got
a huge tablet when you guys see me
online I'm working from a tablet yeah he
doesn't even have a computer yeah or a
cell phone or something for the shift
well call me I'll call you I haven't
called anybody in [ __ ] years well
I'll call my dad every now and then yeah
that's about it I don't like talking on
the phone I'm talking about damn phone I
don't mind if people want to text me
absolutely then when I got old yeah like
a fallback then yeah I was like that's
what and I said that before I was like
so excited when texting and emailing
you've ended because I'm like hooray I
don't have to talk to people anyone on
the phone we're from the [ __ ] Dark
Ages back we're from even back before
caller ID and some youngsters don't even
know a caller ID yeah you had to pick up
the phone to Lexie yes it was you be
like hello
and then sometimes yeah yeah no mumbling
give out give shout out to a friend the
channel weapons and stuff and England
hit once this damn pandemic outbreak hit
his channel [ __ ] blew up he
livestreams a couple times a day and all
he does is explain NBC gear nuclear
biological and chemical gear and you
know he's never served in the military
but he knows his [ __ ] he's one of those
autists sits around and collects NBC
gear and reads all the manual
so you can actually give pretty good
advice so if you want to know anything
about masks or how to protect yourself
against biological agents he'll give you
the whole run run down you sit in their
livestream and like change the chain to
take a couple hundred dollars per
livestream well yeah doing good work to
training people from around the world
how to protect themselves from the what
do they call it the corona virus which
man some videos from China just came out
today of them actually forcibly taking
people out of their homes in the bio
suits and [ __ ] and throwing him in the
back of damn Vance it's a heavy down
here nobody asked us to do a show about
pandemics so this actually not just that
one but you know about like the Black
Death and stuff like that so I think
maybe we'll do that one yeah next time
yeah I have some NBC training myself and
you know you know other servicemen you
know that who are subscribers they know
all about them damn masks drills and
going to mop for it [ __ ] was [ __ ]
torture especially in the summer face
sweat pouring down your face getting
into your damn camo paint or getting
into your bug repellent that was on your
head and it goes into your eyes and you
can't rub your eyes because got the damn
mask on I was like that for flex eight
hours one time nothing but just blinking
and strain and fight and fight in the
[ __ ] bug repellent on Korea in the
summer gross oh man we were [ __ ]
doing that damn simulated [ __ ]
chemical attack [ __ ] that [ __ ] alright
just off the top my head if you're
worried about that [ __ ] the best defense
against any kind of bio stuff is
isolation just don't go out in public
stay home that's the best defense well
but yeah most people have jobs but it's
real bad yes real bad nobody goes to
their jobs depending on what the hell's
happening I mean shot is breaking down
some of those cities are quarantined and
they're just everybody staying home if
it ever got that bad here can't food
rice beans fresh water just stay home a
mask could help you but that's not what
you did that's not really what your life
depends on your life just depends on can
you stay home for a couple months so you
want to look at it that way but
hopefully it won't get that bad here I
mean I think China's in in a special
circumstance
you know I mean they they they don't
quite have the services I think it's
part of it nothing is uh it has been
hypothesized I don't know if it's true
but it might have been an escaped
vaccine that the Chinese were working on
and it was a vaccine to some kind of a
maybe almost kind of like a tailored
race specific bioweapon that maybe they
were trying to because they they won't
give out a sample of what it is and some
of the people is an Indian firm that got
a hold of it and they said man that's
genetically engineer it's got a bunch of
stuff spliced on it you know it had like
some kind of a been a DNA that looks
like it came from the HEA the HIV virus
the part where it actually like the
receptors the thing that gets into you
it's not HIV but there are parts of it
that looked like it came off the HIV
virus it's just weird we won't know
anything till it's here yeah you know
but yeah like I said we might do a show
about pandemics like I said not just
about that bulb talk about like you know
Spanish flu from yeah right yeah Black
Death we're overdue for something like
that well there was one in 2009 actually
that you know there there's been one's
kind of like ongoing it's just you don't
hear about it so much because it's not
as devastating as the ones back in the
day yeah because it's not you know it's
not like widespread death tolls in a
show like that yeah not so much most
people that get it survive that's what I
mean so you don't really I mean you know
it's not like millions dead like the
Spanish flu like back in the early 20th
century you know what I mean so well we
don't know what the lethality rate I
think Spanish flu was only like about
six seven percent I think lethality some
people are saying that the one coming
out of China right now is more like 15
percent some of the people that are
dying are in their 30s so it's not to
kill it just the old
yeah it's killing young people well like
I said we're gonna do this show right
next week probably you're right and
there's nothing you can do if you catch
it you just gonna take tylenol and drink
a lot of water there's no cure ya know
like I said it's just it's just like any
other flu there's really not much you
can do about it right once you get it
then they just you can't really trust
the Chinese data everybody's interested
in this subject you can't trust the
Chinese data
the lethality might be pretty high but
that high lethality might have something
to do with the Chinese condition it may
not be as lethal here a lot of hesitancy
[ __ ] like diet population density how
stressed out the people are in that
environment if their metabolisms are
kind of weak from you know low protein
diets or overworking or even things like
people who don't sleep much might be
more gravely affected by a viral attack
this is no talent or too many factors
yeah all right so let's do I got like a
whole bunch of shoutouts before we get
into the topic of the show um first
thing is if you hadn't noticed we
finally finally probably like a decade
too late finally got on Instagram yeah
Instagram now yeah I think it's like at
this point I maybe have like four photos
on there
well what ended up happening was that a
long time ago I made like a personal
Instagram account and I had like 700
something followers on there but I never
I don't think I ever posted anything on
there so then the other day like Tom
started one and I was kind of like but
you know I should really start one for
the show it's like people keep bugging
me about it and it's like I just never
got around to it
it's mostly because my phone it doesn't
have the memory to have the app but
since I figured out like how to emulate
a mobile phone like on my laptop so I
can post up from my Mac laptop then I
decided well I'll just take my personal
account and transfer it to a 13 o'clock
account and start posting stuff about
the show so we'll just kind of post you
know I'll post all the episodes on there
and it's just like you know I went from
I went on there a long time ago but it
was back when my tablet I didn't have
was a memory expansions yeah you know it
was sucking up a lot of data but I put
those chips in there and then tried it
again I forgot all about Instagram I
even had it already add an account setup
and everything but it works real well
now I wasn't really sure what what
you're supposed to do with yes the
ground well it's just another social
media but you know it's just for more
visually alright then it's a lot better
to trade pictures and videos and
commenting on pictures
videos than Facebook is yeah admit it
has it features a lot like messenger -
yeah so but after a few days of messing
with it I like it so I'm most start
using it a lot more yeah like I said and
I'm gonna start like try and post at
least one or two things a day
yeah that's show related whether it's
just like merch from the show or like
you know new episodes that come out or
[ __ ] like that it's it's also kind of
like a kinda like YouTube it's just
faster astron shorter videos and stuff
yeah mmm it's like YouTube's merged with
social media like you know like I said
it's you know it's been around for such
a long time and it's just I never got
away and so many people have like buy
this like why don't you guys have an
Instagram it's like come on everybody's
on that ship yeah I was just kind of
like okay well finally I got around to
doing one yeah I had it but I wasn't
using them yeah I was yeah it wasn't
either I had to count and it's just like
I was like a bunch of followers but I
never think I ever did a single thing so
I just always forgot about it I was so
worried about [ __ ] Facebook and
Twitter and every and the blog and
everything else so it's like I just kind
of fell by the wayside so yeah so go
check us out we're just 13 o'clock
podcast on Instagram and like I said
there's probably only four or five posts
on there at this stage but I'm gonna try
and post a couple things a day that are
show related maybe you know selfies
about hey we're recording the show or
pictures updates on the show stuff like
that yeah [ __ ] like that personal stuff
I was posting about spam and people
something a lot of people were [ __ ]
thumbs up in that a few guys like spam
and then people were [ __ ] some man
that's that shitty stuff and I'm
blocking now don't you talk bad about
spam spam is gross the spam is awesome
spam war 2020 yeah it's it's I don't
like any meat that comes in a can
except for tuna it is not mystery meat
its pork shoulder no I know but there
there's something there's something like
great it's kind of like how I don't like
um I usually don't like sherbert any
type of things because I'm kind of weird
about like fruit and milk kind of
together yeah with with rare exceptions
I'm the same way about like meat in a
can
yeah there's there's just something that
I found like kind of viscerally
disgusting about that over that from the
except for tuna I don't like tuna yeah I
got over that in the arm
it is a militant type meet I like it's a
military-style food product and you know
world war two with a fam Pollux World
War two would have never happened
without spam yeah it powered the
American army and the Soviet Army I'm
gonna make you assured that this I'm
spam power and empowered yeah I probably
can't sell it cuz I get sued but you
know it's the anti I can make you one
that is anti-nazi meat yeah maybe it's
made of Nazis I don't know
wouldn't that be something yeah least a
photo Japanese a beer or something line
them up and make the sandwich out of
them yeah yeah so so yeah go check out
our Instagram account eat spam if you
want to um also got some shout outs I
would like to give a big THANK YOU to
friend of the show Melanie for one of
her many generous don't PayPal donations
so thank you very much for that also we
got some new patrons yeah hooray we got
one named Justin Justin with a why we
already have one that's Justin with anti
but this is Justin with a why so thank
you very much Joe thank you thank you
for coming in uh we also have Lana or
Lana who I think was a patron before but
then she had to leave but then she came
back
yeah you guys ever have to [ __ ] leave
don't worry you can always come back
that's why I can come back they don't
still love you hey man real life if I
understand man I just had to pay my
taxes I understand how this [ __ ] goes I
paid less this year but that's because I
made less this year
I either made less or I spent more one
of those two things I I you know yield I
don't think you laugh as many books that
last year I did though
you did I think I got like you know what
I think it was was I think when I did
all my taxes and added everything up
because I don't know if you guys know
but like when you're self-employed and
like I have three different income
streams like you know book podcast and
graphic design which I do freelance so I
have to do all those three things
separately like the income the expenses
and then you have to do checks
separately from PayPal and like all this
other kind of [ __ ] I need an accountant
but whatever I use TurboTax and it's
like I just hope I did it right please
don't on at me but um you don't have
anything to take that's what I mean it's
like yeah come get what you want a
dollar I have
forget that they don't argue unless you
got some attack that's what I mean and
they did tell me like they went through
my stuff they show you your audit risk
and my it's always like low they're like
dude you made like 20 bucks this year
it's like no it's fine you don't own any
property or anything right that's like I
said they don't really have anything
they can take from me so except you know
my kidneys maybe yeah it's but you know
what I mean so it's like I know you
never know but yes I think that I got a
little bit less freelance graphic design
work this year I think that's what
probably just because I had already done
like all their packaging and stuff and
they didn't launch as many new that sort
of work I think is what healing
butterfly gave you all those contracts
and makes all those package yeah which I
still did like a lot of work for them
that like it would I don't think I did
as much as I did last year um you know
so it in a way it was good because I was
expecting to pay as much in taxes I paid
last year but I was like well I guess
it's still silver lining it's like I
made a lot less than last year but I
also had to pay a lot less in tax it's
not something at least yeah well this is
gonna be a long show tonight because you
can always tell her already patent it
out with Tech Talks is a talk of taxes
well yeah we have new [ __ ] started
talking and I got to do this in like
four pieces because you're doing four
couples I think that's what we did last
actually I think last year we did just
two because it was like kind of a big
holiday shows tend to be longer yeah
people like it anyway I'm trying to
record this in the middle it's Saturday
afternoon y'all and it's like I really
really really wanted to go out and dance
tonight so I'm really trying to get all
of this recorded before I have to start
going to get ready yeah which means that
I have to start drinking tequila early I
don't know how I'm gonna get there and
get back you'll be all right I'll stop
I'll try to sleep it off before we go
yeah well you like I said it's easier
for you because you don't have to I mean
I take like a lot longer to get ready
than you do
yeah it's like you can probably get
ready like half an hour I take like two
and a half hours like doing all the
hairdo and the makeup and figuring out
what [ __ ] like squeezing my ass and
my clothes and all that other kind of
[ __ ] yeah so you know what I mean
also we have another patron named Trevor
so hey there thank you very much you
guys I would also like to give Rob
another shout-out for sending
even more movies he sent us altered
states which we reviewed last week he
also sent us Solaris the movies a month
yeah with George Clooney so it's like
like I said he sent us 30 days of night
we still need to review that that'll
probably come out like in a week or two
because I want to do a valentine's day
one this week yeah if you guys want it
and then definitely review you know cuz
we have a movie review show too if you
if you want that you gotta send us a a
blu-ray or DVD and Jenny can give you
the address but if you send us the damn
blu-ray guarantees that we will do that
yeah we might not do it like immediately
but we will get around we will do it I
mean cuz I do have I have a schedule but
I will like switch things around it
right we get a lot of requests in the
damn in the comment section do this one
do that one yeah where's the movie well
I have like a big long list and my
highest - well yeah and like like I said
I usually like sometimes if I had one on
the list and like say shutter ads it or
Netflix ads it then I'll push it up the
list cuz I'm like oh there it is let's
review that like before it's gone right
they say I really want to review that
badly then you'd send us the blu-ray
yeah
a blu-ray we'll move that to the front
align DVD it might take a couple of
couple weeks or like I said it's you
know they say we will do it if you said
it this week I had one in mind just
because it was like the holiday week and
I wanted everything this week to be that
theme because I'm kind of me and all the
time so like that all right so I think
that's all the shoutouts did you have
any more now the talk show part is over
this is like a D style every time we
start this show like before I push the
record button I still always hear the
Johnny Carson theme in my head and see
the little rainbow gardens every now and
then we get these little comments in the
comments why aren't they talking about
you this is a this is what we grew up in
the 1970s alright that's when they had
things called talk shows where they
actually sat around on television in a
lot before a live studio audience
drinking and smoking cigarettes and
talking yeah about a subject or just
general of generalities you know like
old Merv Griffin Show
he's the elevator killer yeah yeah the
other vertical yeah weird
true crime and paranormal version of
that and I got to remind the audience
every now and then because we had new
people coming you know it says yeah it's
like it's a long format you get to the
topic eventually it's a long format I
promised are you're commuting and you're
driving or you're in bed damn headphones
on or you're working around the house so
you know I mean if you just want the
facts and [ __ ] go on Wikipedia yeah
that's what I mean yeah there we go you
know you can check this is entertainment
well hopefully yeah usually I start
cutting up the Jenny's dress cut up you
know it's just you know just wait all
shows are like this if it's not like
this then it's not a show yeah like I
said it's a show with a cache oh yeah
all right so since this this is the
Valentine's Day show and as has become
tradition over the last couple of years
we decided we were gonna do true crime
killer couples this is volume three yeah
now it's alarming to maybe I mean killer
couples in general are rare not as rare
as you might think but um so I had to go
I had this humongous list of like ones
that we hadn't done before cuz I think
last year we did like UK so we did like
Brady and Hindley and the we did Fred
and rosemary West last year and we did
kind of the bigger ticket ones like the
year before that I think which Ken and
Barbie killers like Homolka and Paul
Bernardo and like some other people so
this year I just picked for kind of at
random that I thought were interesting
so hopefully you guys think they're
interesting as well so in the first
segment the ones we're going to talk
about this is going all the way back to
the 1940s and these are appropriately
the Lonely Hearts killers otherwise
known as Raymond Fernandez and Martha
Beck these ones are from up in Canada no
okay yeah this one is do I forgot about
yeah this one's kind of interesting
responsible for possibly the deaths of
as many as 17 women and this is a guy
who was originally from Spain but then
moved to the United States and a woman
who was actually born in Florida and how
they kind of met and how they ended up
you know killin people so yeah it's a
weird man that you can get a guy who
likes killing people killing women he's
like a serial killer but then he can get
a woman as a Thrall my god it is very
strange she's like his main fan who
watches him do all this [ __ ] oh and that
is all big time yeah this situation here
I mean this woman like I said and and I
probably brought this up on like some of
the killer couples I'm fascinated by the
dynamic between like the killer couples
and I'm not saying that women can't be
just as evil as men because some of them
are however it is very rare for women to
be serial killers and if they are they
they usually take you know much
different methods so you know I was
watching this one documentary about one
of the other couples that we're gonna
talk about and they you know this
psychologist on there we're saying you
know it's only 5% of your violent crime
it's not just murders but violent crimes
in general are committed by women so
obviously it's kind of a thing where and
I talked about this a little bit when we
were talking about Brady and Hindley
it's like would the woman have committed
these crimes had she not met this guy I
think in a lot of cases probably no I'm
not saying that they're not responsible
for their own actions because they are
I'm just saying that if fate had not
intervened in that way and they met this
guy that happened and they fell in love
with him because like a lot of these
women have very low self-esteem or they
have other issues and so they meet this
guy and they want to do everything to
please him and then it's kind of like a
frog in boiling water situation where it
just kind of like leads up to them
participating in this kind of [ __ ] now
like I said it's you know there are a
small percentage of women that probably
would have done it anyway because
they're just evil [ __ ] but I
think in a lot of situations had they
been left to their own devices I don't
think they would have been serial killer
some kind of synergy that builds up yeah
this guy he has these desires to do this
and then he meets a woman who will
tolerate his desires and he does it he
gets away with it in front of her which
encourages him to do it again yeah
and then his her threshold for tolerance
of it goes up and up yeah point where
all of a sudden she's doing it yeah I
think that's exactly what happens you
know what I mean so some of the victims
that have survived from some of these
cases the victim says that the woman was
worse was worse yeah and in some cases
they are yeah but like I said I'm not
you know like I said I'm not saying that
they're not responsible because
obviously they are and a lot of them are
you know a lot of women have like a lot
of like darkness in there and stuff but
I think a lot of the times it wouldn't
express itself had they not been put in
this situation or put themselves into
this situation where it was like
encouraged for them to be like that yeah
you know what I'm saying that's yeah
that's what I mean I think that happens
in a lot of cases it's some kind of
weird alternate it's like an alternate
sexual we call it orientation yes like a
sexual orientation yeah it yeah it does
kind of seem like it's dream personally
DSF yeah yeah I guess that's one way but
that's kind of [ __ ] up but that is
like white pudding so let's talk about
okay so what I want to do I want to talk
about each one of them like into like up
until you know they met each other and
then we'll kind of get into their you
know killing spree so uh Martha Beck as
she would be known later on
she was actually born Martha Seabrook
now she was born in 1919 in a town
called Milton in Florida now when she
was a very young she actually developed
a glandular condition that not only made
her very very heavy but also made her
sexually mature much younger than most
of her compatriots hmm um so by the time
she was 10 years old she basically had
like a woman's body she had like breasts
and she was had all like the secondary
sexual characteristics and also had a
sex drive to match hmm however um she
was also very very overweight the
glandular you know the condition had
made her overweight as well so she was
actually the target of a lot of bull
which did not help her you know mental
situation um also I think her parents
were kind of like particularly her
mother was like very domineering it has
been said that she was molested that
Martha was molested by her brother when
she was very young and her mother blamed
her and beat her up for it so you know
not so cool so it's sad because I feel
like someone like her who was very heavy
from an early age and she was bullied
from an early age so she kind of wanted
love and it kind of wasn't coming her
way
you know what I mean so I think that
kind of contributed to like some [ __ ]
that happened later on so she goes to
nursing school in Pensacola she
graduated first in her class
in 1942 however she had a hard time
finding a job maybe because she was so
overweight so she ended up getting a job
at a mortuary like preparing like female
corpses for a burial you know what I
mean because that was I guess the only
job she could find in her field um so
she finally she kind of gets sick of
this [ __ ] she moves out to California
she finally gets a job as a nurse in an
Army Hospital and then she would start
because like I said she you know she had
like a kind of a voracious sex drive but
did because of her appearance she was
having a hard time like you know getting
anything for that couldn't get a man
yeah so what she would start to do was
she started like trolling the bars like
picking up soldiers like have you know
having various one-night stands and
stuff like that and this is the 1940s so
you know so she ends up getting pregnant
by one of the soldiers around this time
back then being overweight but it's kind
of rare it was and like I said it
groaning in the forties yeah and like I
said in her case it was a glandular
condition it does appear that it was
like a medical issue and not just like
oh she over a type of thing which is sad
so she gets pregnant by a soldier the
soldier not surprisingly doesn't have
anything and want to have anything to do
with her however when she told him that
she was pregnant he rather
in a rather drama-queen type fashion
threw himself off like a peer into a bay
and killed himself
damn so you know never heard of that
yeah I was like geez that's a little
strange he could have just left I mean
that's what most dudes what do you must
have had a really weird kind of like
background yeah that dish seems like
like I said it seemed like that probably
happened all the time like dudes who
just knock up chicks and be like okay
bye but it's like I was jumping in a
[ __ ] lake that's odd he probably came
from from a small town it was kind of a
young guy very uh how should I say kind
of a very much an honor system you know
an honorable background probably so he
was like oh I have to take care of this
child with a woman I don't love oh woe
is me and they kill himself yeah was
that probably because you couldn't bring
himself to just abandoning the kid yeah
I guess maybe he actually had something
of a conscience I felt bad where's like
I said most guys are probably just like
I know well bye yeah but maybe not in
the forties maybe not I don't know yeah
maybe that was like a kind of a big big
deal you not a man yeah so you couldn't
take it though yeah so as you can
imagine this was not great for Martha's
self-esteem because she's like here's a
guy who would rather die than marry me
so yeah that doesn't really make me
that's not exactly what happened maybe
that's just how she interpreted me know
that well yeah that's how you would
interpret it this is the story were get
maybe he was suicidal for some other
[ __ ] too
it could have been sure but it's ain't
been a bunch of other stuff but it was
related but yeah but it does seem kind
of like this she's like hey I'm pregnant
and he's just like okay many jokes on
the same right it's like can you imagine
like if you're a woman like how that
would make you feel like a real guy I
guess I'm I guess I suck okay so because
of this I can't that's what a B oh
that's weak that's what you would think
and you have to understand this poor
woman I'm not a poor woman because she
did look she was like involved in like
murder and [ __ ] later on but this woman
had been like [ __ ] on her whole life for
being fat essentially handled up a lot
of hate so she had built
probably like a lot of self-loathing and
[ __ ] like that in something like that
she's like well that just cements it
okay so uh yeah so she went into a
depression and moved back to Florida now
at this stage she was still pregnant and
because it was the 1940s she was like
well I got to think of a cover story for
this [ __ ]
so what she did was that she made up a
story that she had married a Navy
officer while she was in California she
even like bought her own wedding ring
and word around it's like oh he'll come
back and also there's like he's out dude
deployed or whatever the [ __ ] she even
she told everybody like about him she
made up a name all this other kind of
stuff and then she said that well she
thought to herself it's like well that
you know I'm gonna get busted if I don't
come up with something so she sent a
telegram to herself that she that he had
died so that she could show it to people
and people bought it to such an extent I
mean I mean if she's from a small town
right Milton Florida which is up in the
Panhandle I think but it's damn near
Mississippi yes so she had me so she
made up the story so everyone felt
really bad for her they're like you know
oh this poor woman and she's pregnant
and now her husband was like deployed
and he died like in combat or whatever
and she like kind of milked it she was
like oh well okay crisis averted
so she had a daughter in 1944 named
Willa Dean now a couple months later she
meets a bus driver in Pensacola and gets
pregnant again
now this person whose name was Alfred
Beck he actually did feel bad and he
actually didn't marry her
which is why she ended up being Martha
Beck later on although he didn't really
seem too jazzed about it he was just
kind of like oh well [ __ ] all right here
we go and that's what happened they were
only married for six months and then
they got divorced now Martha had
actually lost her job not too long
before this so now she had two kids and
she had no money now at this stage it
seems that she kind of went into a
fantasy world like a lot of women of
this kind of this type do where it's
like her whole apartment like once they
searched it was just full of like
romance novel
romance magazines stuff like that so she
is kind of like gone into this
delusional state where she is trying to
find somebody who's gonna take her away
from all this who's gonna rescue her in
case any of you youngsters don't know
they may not know anything about this
the romance novel was the back in the
day it may still be this way now the
romance novel was the old school woman's
equivalent of the damn girly magazine
yeah that's like that's like woman porn
it's woman porn it still is yeah
probably well because I do feel like I
mean because you know we might have
talked about this before but it's like I
in general like I said all of my shits
general all right I'm not saying like
all women do this or all men do that
because that's [ __ ] in general men
are visually oriented yeah women tend to
be more imaginations oh my so I think
that's why like romance novels like in
erotica and stuff like that sells much
better with the female demographic
because they don't like seeing Pro
because there's like I don't know that
dude who is that you know what I mean do
you like to imagine so you can put
yourself in are you with someone that
you're sexually attracted to in it and
you can like put it in your brain and
it's a lot more you know that that turns
women on a lot more than seeing it yeah
in front of their in general in Japan
just aren't wired that way yeah it just
you could describe it all day long it
doesn't mean anything to the guy
actually sees it whereas women are
almost the complete opposite because
because like I said it's easier for them
to like think of their own situation in
their head and personalize it to
themselves which they it's evolutionary
in this hormonal I mean you got people
today you're not I mean these young kids
they're very confused especially with
this some of these modern education that
they're saying that there are no
differences between men and women oh no
no there are a lot of differences you
can it's most love its hormonal I mean
if you take a bunch of testosterone and
inject it into a woman they start acting
like a man they start seeing eye to eye
with a lot of bad because testosterone
is like a damn drug it does make you do
and think and feel in certain ways yeah
there's a guy gets holy s holy yeah
makes you very aggressive I mean high
concentrations of it but it also makes
you very active you know I mean is
I'm hitting 50 now you know I lift which
help does help boost some testosterone
but men lose testosterone over time now
you can do that TRT testosterone
replacement therapy and it you can bring
it back into like the levels of a 20 or
30 year old you sometime might may have
to kind of measure it out do I want to
be like I was back in the [ __ ] 20s
and 30s because you do some stupid [ __ ]
man if I'm gonna say yeah but yeah you
know I mean as testosterone declines in
men you start being kind of sleepy and
happy to stay home she gets pissed she's
like - cotton go man yeah it's like I'm
not gonna dance come on I'm almost as
old as you
yeah but it's just a different situation
yeah I can feel that I can I feel
different
yeah definitely feel different it must
be like a bigger because a bigger
difference back from say like oh I'm not
saying that sometimes I'm 1819 how does
it uncontrollable [ __ ] sexual
psychopath that was it maybe it's
because maybe it's because I've kind of
like low-level felt like crap my whole
entire life anyway so I'm just kind of
like used to like feeling like crap no
I'm just saying so it's like so now it's
just like I kind of feel like crap but
you know whatever and so you just have
to like power through it men
testosterone testosterone will make you
feel like you're on top of the [ __ ]
world see I've never expected man it's
like so yeah it does and it just makes
you feel indestructible like you could
do anything but like I said that that
does end up yeah and you wake in certain
amounts that like that you're just like
being a dick to everyone else around you
yeah it's in high concentration it makes
you very competitive very alpha male
yeah that's what I mean yeah I can you
addicting well everything it's not about
what society thinks it's about what
works and a lot of those guys even
though they're dicks are successful
they're successful in their careers
they're successful at having children
doesn't matter we're not people like or
not it really is it really doesn't
matter that much they're Grayson there's
always a certain market for that yeah
you know but well like I said something
for it
there are differences you know and they
don't teach that nowadays everything
it's not it's not PC well it depends the
thing is there are differences but it it
depends on what you're talking about and
it's hard to say that like you know men
do this women do that because there's
such like a huge spectrum and everyone
is different like individuals are
different like there are some
generalities but I can't say that like
any individual man say is this way or
any individual woman is this way because
I don't know that person
there are generalities but there are
general yeah and it's and here's another
things this there's truth in stereotypes
stereotypes about even racial stereotype
stereotypes about white people they tend
to be true white people black people
even like you know Latino people me
growing up in Brazil there's flecks of
stereotypes there there is because it's
they're talking about the average yeah I
mean yeah it's like the average in any
kind of a group that's where the
stereotype comes from what they're yeah
now the stereotypes will change over
time
yeah you know I mean like you know what
was what was what the stereotypes are
the twenties were is not necessarily the
stereotypes of today yeah yeah I mean
because society changes over times yeah
but yeah there's something to all that I
mean in in general though excuse me
in general though I've never found
stereotypes all that useful because like
I said for a given individual it doesn't
help doesn't really help you deal with
when you're dealing with an individual
because it's like who knows how far away
from the stare exactly it's always it's
like you said it's an average it's an
average so it's like I said to me it
seemed so watered-down that it doesn't
really seem to have any yeah and when
you're oddities like us like me and
you've in the scenes that we never admit
average people really anyway I don't
think I've ever met an average person in
my whole entire life well maybe some
people that I don't know well right you
know what I mean well being in the
military you didn't really run into the
average black guy
it was the average black guy for the
military not necessarily the average
black guy it was and it was the same
thing for the white guys you weren't
running into the average white guy
that's running in the average white guy
do you see that's that's why I say that
stereotypes are useless because I have
never met a person
was like the average because that's what
the average is it's everyone's it's
everyone's personality traits like
watered down to such an extent that it's
like it doesn't really seem wrong I'm
from Mississippi you know I grew up in
Mississippi you know part of the time as
a kid and no they were average miss
[ __ ] that met people pretty close to
the average but they always had like
some quirk or something like that that
wasn't what you would expect yes yeah
well everybody's an individual that's
what I mean everyone I've met has at
least one thing that I didn't expect you
dealing with an individual it's always
face-to-face eye-to-eye it's the
relationship you have to that individual
person right and like I said I'm you
know I'm probably not average by any
means you know by any metric you wanna
bet your average I wouldn't be with you
well yeah but I see you know yeah I
embrace my weirdness it's like you know
what I miss you her and I were buddies
before we even went out for a long time
for a long year and a half so yeah so I
was still married when I met him
although that was going down the toilet
yeah her and I got to be her and I got
together because we got along so well
yeah just even though we're like very
different we're very different couldn't
get rid of each other that's what I mean
it's like in some ways it's like you
kind of tried to get rid of me I try to
kind of try to get ready I'm like I'm
going all this other dude whatever it's
just kind of like
you just kept coming back and being like
what are you doing that game well we
were friends
yeah true we're dating other people yeah
it's just funny I just didn't like my
first time went on we just kind of you
know kind of drew together instead drawn
apart well it's funny too it's like for
a long time before we were even like
kind of going out like officially or
anything everybody thought we were and
we thought we were just because we were
always hung out together and people were
like what the [ __ ] it's like why are you
even bothering it's like just please
like everyone seemed to know before it
was not no but you know what I mean
everyone was just like would you just go
out already there are a lot of
differences between Jenni and I but
there weren't enough differences to make
a difference I guess you could say like
they had different politics and [ __ ]
like that and different [ __ ] opinions
vesser they
way it kind of complemented the team
that's yeah that's what I mean I I do
feel like you had a lot of I mean
particularly one thing that I liked
about you is that you're like a lot more
outgoing whereas I'm very introverted um
I don't really like to do like public
speaking I don't really like to have to
like go up and like talk to people like
hey what's happened like I don't really
do that type of [ __ ] cuz I'm too you
know I'm really shy and kind of like
inside myself all the time a lot of had
to do is we can we can we can approach a
problem from two different yeah and I do
think that that's very helpful um you
know we could tell each other no yeah we
tell each other we were full of [ __ ]
which yeah we did a lot of that that
were the worst of our boo the worst of
our characters kind of got canceled out
trying to stop the other one anyway time
we ever fought cuz we were both the
[ __ ] loaded trail yeah we don't
usually fight will be resolved within a
couple days anyway
well yeah yeah that's true it's just you
know but uh okay so where was I so yeah
we're talking it's the Valentine's Day
show we can do it we can do that kind of
[ __ ] we can we can talk about this is
our show goddamnit part of the show is a
reality show people a lot of people that
listeners are like are kind of like our
friends I guess well that's how I see it
there are yeah I talk to them like all
the time like on YouTube on Facebook and
[ __ ] like that so I feel like I know I
can hop listen to the Howard Stern Show
so I know what what a good show is he
put on a good show especially in his
begin he's been in the prime you know
Howard Stern's crime back and he was
[ __ ] on do you think maybe we need
strippers
we don't need strippers but that was I
didn't know if that's what you were that
was cutting-edge back in that day yeah
now everybody
play it out yeah what made Stern so good
is that he was honest and you guys know
who he was yeah he's a personality
talked about his problems at everything
and I think that's why a lot of people
like even if people thought that he was
obnoxious or a dick or something like
that
he was so um honest about time he's
owned up he was yeah but I think people
like that disarmed people yeah you know
what I mean his thinking and
everything's because he wasn't arrogant
and Robin you know and and who is his
co-hosted so in the drama that was going
on outside the show so the [ __ ] that
Howard Stern Show was not the show it
was the people yeah the topics that they
talked about they were good but that's
not why you were listening to it yeah
and I mean like I said I kind of do that
on our like I'm interested in the topics
and I hope you guys are in certain
topics too but it's like you know if you
just wanted to know like you said if you
just wanted to know about the topic
right then you could just go to
Wikipedia or whatever and read or murder
PD and we'd read about it about and we'd
about it in a way the show is almost
kind of like a reaction video yeah we
can react into this [ __ ] yeah and every
actor was and I like reaction videos you
know I mean you know people react into
things people react and black people
react into heavy metal that was a whole
[ __ ] genre do you know that yeah I
know they'd never listen heavy metal but
then they're listening to they go okay
yeah I like that you know that's a genre
on YouTube I like I like the videos that
are live like people from one country
reacting to like eating candy he came
from another country that's right for
some reason I like those very action
this [ __ ] being like what the [ __ ] is
this [ __ ]
in a way we're reacting to these cases
yeah it's like cuz like I said it's it's
kind of like I don't you know obviously
like I take notes and everything like
that about you know and do research on
the topics and like watch documentaries
if I have to about him and [ __ ] like
that but he doesn't usually I mean he
knows what the topic is but it's like he
doesn't usually unless it's something
like ancient Rome or something you
already knew about he doesn't usually
know about them so this is kind of late
and I don't edit hardly anything out so
in a way it's almost kind of like a
livestream yeah we accept a lot because
we have to tell this story
and explain the show at least once a
year okay well in keys they're like why
the [ __ ] where's Tom do with the foot
tom is the audience he's the audience
surrogate I'm a surrogate for the
audience a lot of times there's a couple
shows where I led the show because it
was a topic that I was into knew about
you know but sometimes I you know react
more or less or chip in more depends on
the situation but really I'm that I'm
the audience that's that's that's what I
do on this show that maybe that mommy Ed
McMahon Johnny that's right I'm just as
much of a dick as anything man didn't do
[ __ ] he's like what what job at my job
that's good that's a good explanation of
the dynamic mm-hmm hey he announced the
show he was like you know yeah anything
man had an easy job he did yeah yeah
he's a job just kind of had this amount
of money he was kind of like I don't
want to say he was like the straight man
but he was just kind of like like he
said he was like the reaction dude he
was the reaction dude he was the
audience because Johnny didn't want to
sit up there in that desk by himself
well it's a little weird like sitting
there like the few times that I've had
to do the show by myself it's like I'll
do it but it's always the people
watching you it's very strange
yeah even though I'm just in my own
office like rocking I feel like who the
[ __ ] why am I talking to myself yeah
it's like crazy right well that's
exactly what it's easier to just like
talk to you and we're talking about the
we're talking about [ __ ]
personalities that are long gone you got
to be at least [ __ ] 45 to understand
who had well you know old people
we're all people now but well that's all
right that wasn't that was pac-man you
only had a couple channels of television
to watch yeah I used to watch it with my
grandma yeah I love [ __ ] tonight's
show yeah cuz it's like I would stay at
my grandma's house a lot and she is she
loved the [ __ ] Johnny Carson so we
would always be able watch it a lot of
times I would fall asleep on the couch
and old David uh terminal
yeah not late-model David Letterman but
80s David Letterman yes [ __ ] yeah yeah
that was a funny show yeah
all right so should we get back to Tommy
it's like I said this is gonna take all
day all right so uh you
Martha Beck so as I said she kind of got
into like the whole romance novel thing
like that that's where we went off on a
tangent when I was talking about romance
novels and yeah true confession type
Maggie woman stuff like that yeah woman
form yeah um you know and how she was
all into like Charles Boyer and stuff
like that um she actually did end up
getting a job in 1946 in Pensacola as a
nurse at a hospital for children
actually and the weird thing about it
considering what happened later on was
that she actually she was really really
good at her job
and she actually became the nurse
superintendent of the whole Hospital
like she got like a lot of accolades and
[ __ ] like that
so now I've heard two different stories
now either she ended up putting a an ad
in one of those lonely hearts type
columns or magazines or whatever like
they used to have back in the day before
they had like tender and [ __ ] you know
you'd put like a little ad in there
saying seeking marriage yada yada yeah
and it was a trap man don't add don't
mention that it's a trap but yes so so
either she put it in there the more
common story is that a co-worker put an
ad in there for her to make fun of her
which I by that I you know what I mean
that sounds like something that some
[ __ ] would do so although it was
apparently put in there as a prank she
still kind of hoped that well maybe
someone will answer it although the ad
did not mention that she was almost 250
pounds and also did not mention that she
already had two children mmm so you know
now at this stage let's talk about the
other half of this couple because this
is like this ad is gonna be what brings
the two of them together so we'll kind
of go back and talk about the male half
of this killer couple this is raymond
fernandes now he was actually born in
hawaii
his parents were Spanish now apparently
when he was a kid he was kind of like a
very sickly child very skinny and stuff
like that so his dad as a lot of people
did back at this was 1914 when he was
born um was kind of like oh you know
you're no son of mine look how small and
sickly you are in ba ba ba you know what
I mean he's it wasn't masculine
enough apparently so um so I guess the
dad was kind of like [ __ ] on the kid
all the time
now when Raymond was three years old the
family moves to Bridgeport Connecticut
now in 1932 mmm
Raymond by this stage was you know quite
a bit older so he decided he was going
to move to Spain because one of his
uncle's lived there and he said that he
could come to Spain and work on his farm
so while he was in Spain he actually had
20 years old he married a Spanish woman
whose name was and I hope I'm not
demanding this too bad but in karna Seon
that was her name means Encarnacion yeah
that's kind of a cool name actually yeah
all those Catholic countries they do
[ __ ] like Cohn sis don't say so which is
Concepcion yeah at all so he didn't
macula concern you imagine if you're
walking out with your name being
Concepcion like in English yeah yeah
yeah I mean and I've heard of like a lot
of people from you know spanish-speaking
countries whose names were like
concepción yeah like that which is a
cool name but like I said in English it
doesn't sound quite so cool it's like me
being named this was Catholic it's like
being named [ __ ] yeah yeah
Annunciation is the [ __ ] the word that
was spoken to make God's enunciation I
believe that's what they're talking
about yeah well her name is Encarnacion
incarnation yeah incarnation pronouncing
robles incarnation incarnate the son of
God yeah so this so he married her and
set up a house you know what I mean so
in in 20 it when he was 20 so he
actually ended up even though he'd been
a very sickly child he actually grew
into like a pretty like good-looking
like you know we'll built
individual now he was actually by all
accounts in his early years quite a nice
dude very gentle very calm very
laid-back nothing wrong with him at all
a second world war started and he goes
and serves in Spain's Merchant Marine he
also later went on to work for the
British government as a spy you know
what I mean so now what ended up
happening and this is something that
comes up on a lot of our serial killer
shows so after the war was over in 1945
he decides that he's going to move to
the United States and look for work
there and then if he finds a job he's
gonna send for his wife and they've also
had a son in the interim so he's
like you know we're all gonna move over
here now when he was on the ship that
was heading for it was actually going to
the Dutch West Indies when he was on the
ship he was coming up on the deck and a
steel cover like the hatch cover fell on
his head and fractured his skull so
here's our good old friend the head
injury and you know people have said
like so the ship docks in December of
1945 and he you know his skull is
fractured obviously so they put him in a
hospital and he was in the hospital
until March of 1946 for three months now
by all accounts when he came out of the
hospital after this head injury his
personality had completely changed which
is something that happens a lot with a
lot of serial killers not all of them
have had head injuries in their
childhood but it is a very very common
occurrence of people have had a head
injuries it won't make you a serial
killer yeah I had one that's what cost
me my military career but I'll tell you
what that first year boy you're [ __ ]
emotionally volatile if it's a major
head injury yeah I think what happens of
these guys is that they already kind of
have some weird-ass tendencies the head
injury axe axe is some of the kind of
limits their inhibitions yeah start
acting on these weird weird ass [ __ ]
oh yeah that's what I think this is all
about I think that does that yeah and a
lot of edge to do with what Tom was I
think a lot of has to do with what phase
of development they're in yeah like it
happens young when it happens young then
they develop it it changes their
development they go it causes them to
like turn a corner and go down a weird
path at that point yeah because the head
injury honor your older guy doesn't seem
to be dude doesn't seem to do that yeah
like you said I do I you know I don't
know if like you know the people you
know I guess a lot of people have had
injuries and they don't like you said
they don't end up being serial killers
but it depends on what part of the brain
is affected usually if it's something
like the frontal lobe or something like
that because that is something that like
will lower inhibitions
so that might just be releasing
something that was maybe already in
there or that maybe everybody has and
you know just your sense of propriety
like keeps you from doing [ __ ]
you know we've all been in the [ __ ]
grocery store line and wanted to
strangle somebody yeah but it's like
that first year the recovery I'd say
felt like I'd had about a six-pack or
maybe like a 12-pack of beer my system
yeah no matter what yeah because it took
you a long time to you get everything
cuz he go yeah it was it was a
motorcycle motorcycle wreck yeah and it
messed your head all up yeah well didn't
mess my head all up I was in a coma for
a couple of days and when it came out
you know could took me a few weeks
before I could walk straight I don't
want to walk in a damn circle yeah it
was weird
yeah that's great yeah and then about a
year of emotional volatility yeah yeah
you want to fight or was fighting a
[ __ ] or crying yeah or like super you
Spock not a man it's just weird yeah
weird your your emotions would be
amplified yeah but it fades though cuz
people used to think that the brain
can't heal it can oh yeah and it can and
it can come up with workarounds Yeah
right given enough time yeah it takes
time takes time and like I said
depending on what part of the brain it
is but in in a lot of ways sometimes it
can kind of like you know take alternate
pathways to like get I got some of the
best treatment that went to Walter Reed
Army Hospital they were pumping me full
of like anti-inflammatories and they
were doing weird weird stuff you know
[ __ ] brain scans and stuff so yeah
yeah you heal up yeah it's eventually
unfortunately I don't know if it
happened for this guy like I said he was
in the hospital a long time but like I
said when he got out he was no longer
than nice guy that he had been when he
was in his early 20s he was now yeah he
was now very like emotionally volatile
very quick to anger he like would ramble
when he talked [ __ ] like that and like I
said his injury was in his frontal lobe
yeah so after he gets out of the
hospital he buys passage in another ship
which is going to Alabama now when it
arrives at port he took a whole bunch of
stuff from the ship's storeroom like a
bunch of clothes and stuff that were
belong to other passengers or other
crew members and he just stole them now
but the stupid thing was like when he
gets off the ship and is going through
customs they caught him because they're
like what is all this stuff it's not
yours so they asked him why did you
steal all this stuff and apparently he
said I don't know I can't say why I did
it
I just saw other men putting a towel or
two in their bag so I thought I'd do the
same
mm-hmm so clearly he's not right yeah he
just said he couldn't seem to stop like
putting stuff into his bag like he saw
other people putting stuff in the bag
and he just kept putting stuff in the
bag so he just said so he got arrested
now while he was and now this is the fun
part of the story so while he's in
prison for the theft in Tallahassee his
cellmate was a Haitian man who was into
voodoo yeah and he apparently like
Fernandez got super interested in voodoo
and asked the guy to teach him all about
it
so as he was in prison learning all this
stuff he started to become convinced
that voodoo was giving him like sexual
power over women and that he didn't
necessarily have to be like in the same
room with them but he could like affect
it from a distance you know what I mean
yeah it's called spirit [ __ ] that's
what yeah it's a common fantasy so he so
he got the psychopath yeah that his guru
powers would just like make panties drop
like all around him
oh that's he apparently really became
convinced of that like I said head
injury head injury yeah so Raymond gets
out of prison in 1946 he's actually
Ashley projected and [ __ ] these women
down in an astral form and they don't
even know it I didn't know it and he
comes back claims victory probably I got
that every for some reason I just
thought it I don't know if you guys know
there's this song called who the [ __ ]
did that song it was like that that
weird Russian punk band [ __ ] it's called
unvisible zed and it was basically about
an invisible like a ghost and he was
like you know giving oral sex to this
one woman getting her pregnant stuff and
she didn't even know because he's
invisible
like it's a funny [ __ ] song I'll
think of a band later on obviously it
like is obviously a beta male fantasy
but he apparently like I said he really
didn't believe it so and he was already
married had a kid to everything like
that but it's like now he's like gonna
use a voodoo you gotta use voodoo to
seduce women by voodoo can do anything
food who can steal a man's [ __ ] that's
true yeah we can't get on we did a whole
[ __ ] show on that well the whole show
wasn't on Cox yeah [ __ ] ceiling but it
did come up when we were talking yeah we
did a voodoo show there are certain
places in Africa where you can convince
a man that you took his dick from him
even though he gave money even though
it's still there but somehow you did
that well that one is just like you know
he's just imagining that it's there it's
not really there and I don't understand
how I can understand maybe you can
convince a guy that you took away his
power to get an erection but huh that
seemed like it would be fairly data do
yeah more more believable yeah but in
but there's a whole nother genre of
somehow using vu to steal a man's dick
yeah and then they like literally yeah
and then even they like put your pants
down it's still there and he said no
it's not there I know it's not there
it's not there anymore no dude do you
10p maybe it's some kind of weird body
dysmorphia where he really doesn't see
it right cause it'd be like 10 people
going no dude you got a dick it's there
he didn't take it
no it's gone that's like a little
kitchen I got your nose got your penis
yeah yeah if you're not watching on
Piers of Liz's the VI was making like
the littleness yeah yeah except it was
penis alright so um so Raymond gets out
of prison in 1946 and he moves to
Brooklyn where his sister lives now
apparently um he used to be like quite a
good-looking man like before he went
into prison but when he came out he
looked he's lost most of his hair and a
big-ass [ __ ] scar on his head from
where the thing fell on him all this
other kind of [ __ ] he also like acted a
lot different which they noticed right
away he had like a lot of really bad
headaches and during this time period he
also decided that he was going to start
writing letters to all these lonely
heart
magazines and that he was going to like
the women that replied he was basically
just going to like scam them out of
money so that's how he decided that he
was going to make his living from now on
yeah was like and this is where our two
lovebirds actually end up meeting so um
what's funny is late 18-hundreds early
1900s there was a lot of this scam and
women yeah there's a big scamming of the
women motif in a lot of crime oh yes if
women had a lot of money and power back
then
yeah that's one thing that I thought was
a little odd now it I mean some of them
obviously did maybe it was family money
or something like that because yeah like
I said you know women weren't really
like well they're not saying they
weren't allowed to have jobs cuz they
were but it wasn't like to such an
extent that it seems like it was some
kind of Victorian thing yeah
you notice that like something there was
a lot of that check Lorien era where you
have these like bottom-feeding males
running around trying to steal money
from old ladies usually yeah who had all
kinds of money yeah those yeah exploit
some kind of weakness yeah because they
thought oh well this woman is older or
maybe she's funny-looking or something
like that and it's like they could take
advantage of her by flattering her cuz
they said well it's not like she's got
like a whole bunch of suitors knocking
her door down so maybe if I'm nice to
her then I can get all this [ __ ] I
wonder how much of that's going on today
probably not that much because
everyone's cynical and probably rightly
so yeah that was more of a time of
innocence where people that's what I
mean where it's like well how could you
do such a thing because people suck
that's how but I feel like um yeah I
mean nowadays I I'm not saying that you
couldn't get away with it nowadays cuz
it does still happen but I think it's a
lot rarer nowadays just because everyone
is like yeah no closest thing I can
think of today in the modern era would
be like he's European women they go down
to like Jamaica and the women are in
their 60s and 70s they're picking up 17
or 18 year old Jamaican guys yeah as if
that 18 year old Jamaican guys really
into this
although maybe they just want to be
what's that maybe they just want the D
yeah old lady yeah but I'm talking yeah
they do and maybe she's just like I will
I'm the dick I'm just gonna pay for it
anyway so I might as well like get some
young guy that can actually let keep it
up for that long yeah yeah that's
exactly what it is they said they're
getting something out of it they're
getting something out of it but they're
also the the guys getting something out
of it too yeah so is it so I don't
really think anyone's being taken
advantage of in that situation because
they're probably just prostitution yeah
yeah they're the guys just a gigolo
money now they get married yeah
sometimes they get married yeah
I haven't heard about that so much but
yeah yes it still happens sometimes they
get married yeah yeah but so alright so
Fernandez starts writing all these
letters to Lonely Hearts columns and
stuff like that so 1947 he starts
writing to this woman named Jane
Thompson now she had been recently
separated from her husband and was you
know kind of lonely and stuff like that
so he starts writing to her flattering
her stuff like that so finally they
agreed to meet up in October of 1947 now
using her money because apparently she
had quite a bit
they bought cruise ship tickets and went
all around Spain and had like a two-week
vacation it was apparently very nice you
know I mean had hotel rooms like nice
restaurants all this kind of [ __ ]
now if you'll remember Hernandez was
still or Fernandez rather was actually
still married to his first wife so he
ends up going to this place called La
Linea
in Spain which is where his wife lived
and they also had two kids at this stage
the weird thing was he introduces this
woman to his wife and then the three of
them like go out and like do [ __ ] I'm
not sure like who he told this woman
that this was right you know what I mean
so I guess no one suspected anything at
first however in early November of 1947
apparently the two women got in some
soap type of altercation maybe because
the wife was like no I'm his wife did he
not tell you that or I didn't know just
doing what a man try
to do everything back in the day trying
to build a harem so the two women barely
got it I don't know if it was a physical
fight or anything like that but they get
in a fight and apparently witnesses saw
Fernandez the guy like running out of
the hotel room like in the middle of the
night cuz apparently trying to get away
from the state now not so funny but the
next morning Jane Thompson was found
dead in her hotel room causes unknown
yeah her body was removed and buried
there was no autopsy now um on a side
note what's that for you me and out
there don't try to build a harem
well that knowmaybe girl without sale
try to build a harem but just knows
anybody needs to hear that yeah it's not
gonna work we have personal friends that
have tried to build harems and all hot
people involved in this damn harem it
explodes after about six months it's
yeah it might work out for a little
while it's it know those girls start
fighting me why wouldn't you and then
they hang up on the dude yeah that [ __ ]
only works in Islamic countries somehow
now we they got it we do know what the
people that that have managed to like
over many years have a bunch of
different open relationships but not the
same person for a long time it's usually
like it's a couple and then they have
got third like this but then like every
year every change about they have a
different changing one that does seem to
work out yeah but these ones where cuz I
have to say I know they're like people
that are polyamorous and stuff like that
I'm not talking about those the
comfortable while the club scene people
if you saw I mean is it like Instagram
type looking model type people okay
usually it's guys in bands that have
these girlfriends that are some kind of
a dancer or some kind of a model and he
kind of has the charisma to collect like
two or three of them it wants in it he
just look he's a king for a couple
months until those girls [ __ ] turn on
him well because I feel like what is on
each other what ends up happening is
that in those types of situations I
think that a lot of times guys like well
if I got one
girl I could get more than one hot girl
and then he'll say like to her hey honey
how about we do that and then she's like
she doesn't really like the idea but
she's like well he might leave if I say
you know yes
okay maybe it'll be okay and maybe she's
under the chick - yeah there's a lot of
that bisexual women well there's too
many [ __ ] egos involved that's what I
mean after a while you're gonna get to a
thing where the first chick is like hey
I'm the original chick here yeah why why
do you keep looking at that girl like
what you know what I mean it's just not
gonna work out and then like you said
after a while the two girls are gonna
like befriend each other and their baser
turn man [ __ ] this [ __ ] it happen two
different ways that can go down it's
we've seen it's not in demand it's not
in the man's advantage in the long run
yeah I mean they might have a good time
like in the short run sure um but you
know what I mean I think like 90% of the
time maybe 95% of the time if you ever
see like threesomes are like being
polyamorous if that seems like it's like
almost always the dudes idea although
sometimes [ __ ] just kind of happens
that's true and that's a different
situation that's not like a calculated
yes oh [ __ ] [ __ ] just happens and it
doesn't happen again so yeah we're not
we're not a so yes so um yeah so Jane
ends up dead in her room
as I said they didn't do an autopsy
however a little bit later suspicions
kind of started swirling that she had
been poisoned
so they exhumed her body now while they
were exhuming the body or when they were
going to exhume the body Fernandez was
like well I need to get the [ __ ] out of
here because apparently allegedly he did
kill her so he got the [ __ ] out of there
leaving his wife and children alone in
Spain again yeah so he gets back to the
US on a boat he shows up at Jane the
woman he is killed allegedly he shows up
at her apartment
New York and he had a forged will from
her that said hey before she died she
said that I can have all her stuff yeah
and people bought it yeah so he got all
of her stuff now a Jane's mom lived in
this [ __ ] apartment so this [ __ ]
stranger shows up and it's like oh by
the way it's mine
so I don't know if he kicked the old
woman out or what I'm assuming he
probably did but he took all over [ __ ]
yeah so okay now so during this time
while he was kind of like taking all of
this woman [ __ ] and then killing her one
of the women that he had been
corresponding with was the
aforementioned Martha Beck so meanwhile
as Fernandez has been continuing to
write letters and stuff like that poor
old Martha who's in Florida doing great
at her job and [ __ ] like that but has
not been getting a single reply to her
ad which like I said I'm not sure if she
put that in there or if her friend put
it in there whatever but she didn't get
a single reply to it until she got a
letter right around Christmas Day of
1947 from none other than raymond
fernandes his was the only letter that
she was sent now Raymond in this letter
said that he was from New York City he
said that he was originally from Spain
which is not entirely true he was
actually born in Hawaii even though his
parents were Spanish he said he was a
businessman in the import-export trade
which that's a red flag right there
whenever anybody says that yeah you
never know what that means um apparently
the letter was like really sweet said oh
I just moved here you know to the US for
better business opportunities yada yada
I live by myself in this big huge
apartment it's way too big for me I
would like to share it with a wife all
this kind of stuff
he also flattered her by saying I see
that you were a nurse and that means you
know you're very generous of spirit and
you have a big heart and everything like
that so Martha unsurprisingly was super
jazzed about this letter apparently she
took it with her everywhere she went and
like read it and reread it and
everything so she starts writing back to
him like she apparently went and bought
like super special like expensive
stationery and everything too so she
goes and starts writing back
so over the next couple weeks they wrote
back and forth a bunch of times now
there came a stage where they were going
to exchange photographs and she did not
really want to send one because of her
weight so what she ended up doing was
she sent him a picture of her but she
was with a bunch of the other nurses at
the hospital and she was like behind a
couple of the other ones that me feel
kind of but it's like yeah so she did
that she's like oh it doesn't really do
me justice this is the only photo I have
a lot bigger as you know right and it's
like that's so shitty but it's like
taller than actual size right well you
know I've been there man it's like you
know it's a hey it's like get in front
of me a little bit my pictures though I
know but I'm just saying that that's
kind of something that a lot of girls
that grope chubby like I did yeah that's
like something a lot of people do it's
like you know what I mean just kind of
like taking a selfie from like an angle
like way up here and stuffs and I've
been seared all the chins and whatnot so
yeah so uh although some of those skinny
[ __ ] we know do that
that's true well everyone looks better
like that it just makes your face like
your your face looks sharper it's like
even if you're even if you don't have
double chins or you're not heavy or
anything like that it does actually look
a lot better like from that angle
everybody knows that so what apparently
Martha did not know was that it didn't
really matter what she looked like
because raymond fernandes had only
written to her because he was going to
defraud her like he had his other women
that he was writing to him so he didn't
really care about it he just assumed
that because she was a nurse that maybe
she had a lot of money and he thought
that that was something that he could
exploit so after a few letters he
actually asked for a lock of her hair
and she thought that that was really
sweet and romantic but what he wanted it
for was for voodoo purposes because like
I said he's got a nose filling yeah he
was basically gonna cast a spell so that
she would be like it would be like
irresistible guys so it's like it's just
like two [ __ ] different things going
on right there so yeah so he does like a
voodoo ritual apparently with this lock
of hair
so she yeah she was like super jazzed
about it she said him the hair was like
she's braid perfume on it and everything
like that right yes so so finally after
that happened I guess he thought while
the voodoo ritual has been successful
that I have done so I can actually go
down there and meet her in person and
she will be unable to resist my sexual
prowess yeah so he takes a train down to
Florida and she's gonna meet him at the
train station she's very nervous because
she's very heavy so he ends up coming to
Pensacola in December on December 28
1947 now he um you know I I don't know
if he felt that you know oh she's big
and fatter because like I said he didn't
really seem to care about the woman how
old they were if they were fat or
whatever it's like because he was just
trying to get their money so I don't
think he really gave a [ __ ] what she
looked like I'm sure he expected them
all to be kind of ugly anyway maybe
that's what it was now it's like now he
was a he wasn't it was he wasn't a
great-looking mom he was actually a
pretty okay looking dude he was so you
know fairly handsome
I thought you said prison [ __ ] you MA um
yeah he didn't look as good when he got
out of prison but he was a good-looking
dude before that um you know what I mean
and when he came out he wasn't um he
wasn't ugly or anything like that he was
a pretty good-looking dude especially
for back then um so she was like very
excited because she thought he looked
just like Charles Boyer like the actress
that's the actor that she was super into
so um so they kind of hit it off like
she takes him back to her house
introduces him to the kids and once the
kids are in bed
Raymond starts puttin the moves on
Martha and apparently they let's put it
consummated their relationship he knocks
em boots
apparently so um yes so they so they
spend a couple of days together like
humping he's trying to get information
out of her as what he's trying to do
like how old much money she's got and
all this other kind of [ __ ] um but
however Martha thinking that he's
sincere she immediately starts talking
about getting married but he did not
want to marry her obviously because then
that would like you know tie their
financials together and he didn't want
to
they just want to take her money and get
the [ __ ] out of there so the more that
she started talking about marriage the
more he was kind of like yeah I got some
[ __ ] to do back in New York my business
is calling so I'm out of here
so then 18 hundreds you would have
married her the cloud record-keeping
wasn't that good remember we heard other
cases were dude married like he would
marry oh but you would go across the
hills really rocks over there marry that
one he died like [ __ ] 20 wives
like I said oh yeah back in those days
yeah you could just [ __ ] poison
mother yeah yeah so yeah so he basically
just said okay well I got to go and
later on it's like oh I'll be back soon
or I'll send you some money so you can
come see me in New York or some [ __ ]
like that and obviously he didn't have
any intention of doing that
so but because I guess he had been
fairly convincing so he gets on the
train and he goes back to New York and
she Martha starts going around town
telling everybody oh I'm gonna get
married again like I'm you know I met
this guy and he wants to marry me and
yada yada and all of her family and
friends and stuff like that like gave
her a bridal shower because I guess they
bought it like what it's kind of like I
said it's kind of sad because she
actually really did think that that all
this was gonna happen so on the same day
that this bridal shower took place she
gets a letter from raymond fernandes in
which he says basically you misread some
signals I don't want to marry so I'm
like that's kind of a downer right there
Martha tried to kill herself she did not
succeed however because uh she Ramos she
gave the kids okay
yeah because Raymond apparently had a
little bit of a conscience left he
actually did feel bad that she had tried
to commit suicide so he said okay well
I'll tell you what you can come up here
and visit me so she came up there and
visited and she stayed for two weeks now
when she got back to Florida though she
for some reason got fired from her job
no one's really sure why I don't know if
it was anything she did or if it was
just you know she got laid off for some
reason I don't know but she lost her job
the employer would not tell her why she
suspected that maybe it was because
people thought you know she was [ __ ]
that guy and they were
married and it's like it was scandal and
blah-dee-blah you know this was back in
the old days but they the employer would
not elaborate on why she had been um on
why she had been fired so she gets her
last paycheck she told everyone that she
she had already changed her last name to
Fernandez so she's like jumping the gun
big time she basically picked up her
last paycheck and took the first bus to
New York to stay with to stay with him
so she basically just turned up on his
doorstep uh with her kids so he's kind
of like well [ __ ] because his whole
career is made out of like you know
scamming and killing women and here's
this woman and two children turning up
on his doorstep and he's not really
entirely sure what to do about it
um so he tells her he's like okay well
you can stay but the kids have to go Dan
so she left her kids at the Salvation
Army Jesus she just left them she's a
[ __ ] psycho that's how like desperate
she was she's a psycho yeah so she just
abandoned her son in 1948 that's a red
flag right there I mean you know a woman
a woman who's so desperate that she's
gonna [ __ ] over
no dick is that good come on y'all yeah
she's a sucker if you ask me get a
vibrator there's already some problems
that's what I mean she already had like
a lot of emotional problems before this
obviously she was not like a normal
person
no so so I guess at this stage Raymond
thinks well maybe since she doesn't have
much money and since she went to all the
trouble of coming up here and getting
rid of her kids for me maybe she can be
my accomplice so he says you can stay
here and he told her all about his
[ __ ] scams yeah like he showed her
all the letters and everything like that
he's like this is what I've been doing
this is what I do for a living I go
around telling women how much I love
them and I'm gonna marry them and then I
take their money and sometimes he killed
them and sometimes not sometimes he just
took off he also told her that he was
already married that his wife was in
Spain and everything like that so Martha
like I said probably stupidly she's
already given up her kids for this
at this point so she just probably
thinks well she might as well go all in
so she is now becoming his accomplice so
she actually helped him pick out the
next victim yeah variable as she's
already a psycho for leaving her kids
yes I mean there are a lot of women out
there that are not good girlfriend
material they're not what guys are
looking for
they'll can even have kids and they can
spend they can spend their whole life
being good mothers and being happy yeah
they're single
but there's other [ __ ] you can do in
life that's what I need guys it's not
really worth it that much you know it's
not and there are a lot of women that
are in that in that position that I've
had kids have been good mothers and
raised good kids that's what I mean I
feel like magic obably you don't need a
man if you don't really need the man
that much no no it's like just
concentrate if you have the kids just
concentrate on making them good citizens
yeah you got the romance novels you
don't mean you go like I said [ __ ]
toys yeah buy a vibrator get some real
answer hands and years of the [ __ ] you
can do you know even back in those days
they handle this [ __ ] they can do yeah
it's you know so it's it's really like a
nod the kids really you're not a man
[ __ ] then you know better than being
a cat lady
oh no nothing wrong with me a lady but
you know I wouldn't mind bein Academy
cats are awesome yeah their own children
I'm sayin ya heard giving up the
children man that's [ __ ] worst and
give it up to cats that's what you're
talkin about
yeah that's [ __ ] up yeah that she
would just do that for a dude she
probably kids yeah but like I said she
had probably never had well I don't know
if she had never had sex before um I
mean I think she had been sexually
molested before brother but yeah but
it's like so but she had never been she
had always been like kind of [ __ ] and
abandoned right so the way that he
talked to her made her believe that he
was gonna stick around and then I think
that you know she may not had any
girlfriends either they could talk
tok-san Center maybe it seemed like she
kind of like worked and that was it yeah
you know what I mean like she and she
was really good at her job she was a
nurse um so but I I don't know if she
had like any close relationships not
anyone how about a minute underdeveloped
in the [ __ ] yeah and I feel like she
wasn't real close with her face
Emily or anything like that so she was
kind of like in a way I want to say she
was kind of like ripe for the picking
because she seemed like very
self-loathing and might have had a
childlike mentality because she really
didn't have any close relationships to
anybody yeah I think that was definitely
an issue so yeah so she helps him pick
out the next victim and this is a woman
named Esther hen who lived in
Pennsylvania so Martha and Raymond go
down to Pennsylvania to meet up with
this woman now Raymond tells Esther that
Martha is his sister-in-law for some
reason and he's like oh yeah I just I
take her everywhere I don't know it just
seems like really weird like for LA she
come with me yeah it's like it just
seems like a weird it's like why don't
you just say like your sister maybe
because they didn't look enough alike or
something like he thought nobody would
buy that I say there's a cousin or some
[ __ ] yeah so yeah so they go down there
and I guess Esther bought that a week
later Esther and Raymond got married in
Fairfax Virginia then now Esther
actually didn't end up getting murdered
but she later like went to the police
and like later told reporters about what
had happened to her and she said he was
really nice to me for the first four
days like after we got married then he
started haranguing me about signing over
my insurance policies and my teachers
pension fund yeah and got mad when I
wouldn't do it because he's no killer
right so at that point she was like yeah
no thank you and she got the [ __ ] out of
there um and also I think she had
started to hear like rumors about him
that he had a wife in Spain and that
like there was a woman that had died in
Spain which was true that maybe has
something to do with him and maybe he
had something to do with that so she was
like she got the [ __ ] out of there he
did manage to get her steal her car and
he stole like several hundred dollars
but she got out with her life luckily
now that did not seem to stop Raymond at
all him and Martha just started you know
going after other people in the Lonely
Hearts columns one of them was named
Myrtle young she was from Arkansas
she said that she would marry raymond
fernandes so they got married in august
of 1948 in Cook County Illinois
Martha posing as his sister this time
not his sister-in-law cause like I said
maybe everyone just thought that was a
little weird
now Martha because I guess she thought
that she was Raymond's you know woman so
and she's like oh we're just like
scamming these women for the money so
even though he married this woman Martha
like conspired to like not let them
sleep in the same bed together so she's
like doing all this stuff like behind
the scenes like imaginations and stuff
so it's like she would sleep in the bed
with the woman it's like she would I
think they'd she ended up like causing
such a stink that Raymond gave the gave
the woman like a bunch of drugs or
something like that like to get her to
go to sleep like the bunch of sleeping
pills and [ __ ] so [ __ ] yeah so they
gave her all these sleeping pills and
then they took $4,000 off of her now she
had had so many sleeping pills that they
carried her on they put her on a bus and
like left her there the bus took her to
the hospital and then she died
the next day in the hospital from like
an overdose of sleeping pills and they
stole $4,000 from her so at this stage
so Raymond to Martha keep like what if
they knew I see I don't know I don't
know I don't think they gave a [ __ ]
right you know what I mean I just said
they just wanted the money and they're
just like whatever it was she's not our
problem anymore
right that just seems like what they're
whole and I was so they start making
their way back east and they would like
stop at each town like meeting various
women and like running the scam on them
now they did manage to like steal some
money at some various points but none of
the women really seemed like a good like
a long-term like we're gonna you know
he's gonna marry this woman and like
take all her [ __ ] and then kill her or
anything like that so they kind of went
around and then they came back to New
York and started going through the ads
again you know they hadn't had like a
really good scam in a long time so their
money is starting to you know lesson or
dwindle or whatever
neither of them had jobs at this stage
so they finally come across this
woman whose name was Janet Fay now she
was 66 years old she was a widow she was
from Albany New York
and so Raymond thought that she looked
like you know a prize victim so he
started writing to her now Janet had
apparently quite a bit of money also had
a very nice apartment
and had a habit of writing letters to
Lonely Hearts clubs and apparently she'd
been warned about you know people taking
advantage her of her like from family
members and stuff like that but she
still kept doing it cuz I guess she was
lonely she was also very religious and
once Raymond found out about that he
like you know laid on the Catholic
really hard and was you know trying to
get into her that way so they wrote back
and forth for a few weeks
Raymond said that so he was going to go
up to Albany and meet with her just
before New Year's Day in 1948 now he
shows up in Albany with Martha and they
check into a hotel as mr. and mrs.
Fernandez they were not married not
legally so then the next day he shows up
at Janet's house with some flowers and
they hang out you know for the day he's
like talking he's playing on the
religion like really thick and
everything now he kind of like primed
the pump for a few days and then a few
days later like he introduced her to
Martha who he called his sister so the
three of them like kind of go around
like you know eating dinner out like you
know doing fun stuff around the city
Janet let them sleep in hid in her
apartment although she didn't sleep with
Raymond because I guess she thought that
was like improper or whatever but the
but Raymond and Martha slept in her
apartment
so then Raymond asked Janet to marry him
and she said yes now so basically she
had bought a different apartment for
them to live in and he convinced her to
go around cleaning out all of her bank
accounts so in early 1949 she goes
around she gets it like $6,000 like back
in 1949 money money which was like quite
a bit so then Raymond is like okay well
you have
all the money now let's let's move
somewhere else let's move out of Albany
so they end up leaving Albany and going
to Long Island now apparently they so
Martha is still with him at this point
so they're at this apartment in Long
Island and Raymond falls asleep and
apparently I don't know like no one
really knows what happened at this stage
like between Martha and Janet because
Raymond was asleep so he left the two
women like in the apartment and Martha
later said I was just burning up with
jealousy and anger she said that she got
up and she saw that Janet had gone into
Raymond's room and was like laying in
the bed with him now Martha said that
she was naked but I don't know if that's
true or not that's just what Martha's
saying so she's already pissed at this
point because she thinks that he's
paying too much attention to this other
woman so Martha so Martha and Janet into
this big fight Janet says I won't allow
you to live with us you're the most
brazen [ __ ] I've ever seen that's what
the quote was so they have a big
argument like Raymond is awake at this
point so then Raymond says to Martha
keep this woman quiet I don't care what
you do
now Martha later said that she blacked
out conveniently and did not remember
exactly what happened she said that when
she came to again that Janet's body was
laying at her feet and she was bleeding
from a severe head wound I don't believe
that she had been bludgeoned with a
hammer yeah she [ __ ] beat that one
with a hammer yeah she remembered it she
just want to say it yeah is it like I
said that's what she said at trial she
said oh he just yelled at me and I
salute then I don't remember what
happened I just woke up and she was
laying on the floor with blood coming
out of her head because someone had hit
her with a hammer she had also been
strike like strangled with a scarf which
had been tied like a tourniquet around
her neck yeah so apparently she said she
was in some kind of trance blah blah
blah it's like so the two of them like
cleaned up they they wrap the body like
up in sheets and stuff and then put it
in a closet and then kind of what just
went to bed like with the body in the
closet
the next day they go and buy a trunk and
they put the body in the trunk then they
go over to Raymond's sister's house and
say hey we have this trunk can we keep
it in your basement so they put the
trunk with the body into the sisters
basement and then like a more than like
a little less than two weeks later they
come back and they get the trunk and
then they rent a house and then they put
it in the cellar and like cover it up
with cement right so then they go cash
all janet's checks and they typed a
bunch of letters to her family saying
that she was fine she had you know she
you know this new husband she has his
awesome blah blah blah and we're gonna
go to Florida and then sent the letters
to all of her family covered up with
cement you have any idea what the [ __ ]
they're talking about now yeah I don't
they just put it in I guess they'd I
don't know they just like put it out at
the floor in this like [ __ ] cellar and
this ran it okay they put it underneath
the floor to cover it was man I think so
that's kind of what that's from from
what I read that sounds like what they
did I wonder if that would actually keep
the smell in um I guess it would depend
on what kind of cement it was if there
was any error cracks or gases trapped in
there yeah David kind of pressurize a
little bit I don't know why I'm thinking
that just in case it is no because
they're bad guys you know in the past
and it [ __ ] kept dead girlfriends
inside trunks wrapped in plastic and
stuff yeah it was until in the years
later that the the body was found kind
of mummified yeah it makes you wonder
how badly that [ __ ] stank yeah you know
I mean to stake for a long time it's
just that morbid curiosity of me yeah
you can wonder about I don't have my
first and maybe no one was living in
this house so no one noticed it was down
in the cellar and it was under cement
and if the neighbors didn't smell it
then I guess no one would find and maybe
if it was a body weighs a lot when it
starts to decompose I mean the smells
[ __ ] atrocious yeah especially in hot
weather yeah maybe if it's real cold it
decomposes a lot more slowly so the
smell isn't them and now I'm not buying
all that that shit's got a stake yeah
probably yeah
but so could somebody stay in the damn
house okay well like I said the house
might have been empty because they've
rented it particularly for that purpose
cuz they it's just stolen a bunch of
money so how long did they rent that
house okay
but yeah so they just hid the body now
yeah interestingly because they had
typed the letters her family Janet's
family knew that she couldn't type so
they immediately kind of got suspicious
and like reported as the boys and some
so Martha and Raymond left they went to
Grand Rapids Michigan where their next
victim was like their next target now
this was a widow she was only 41 years
old her name was Delphine downing and
she also had a two-year-old kid named
Wayne ow now Raymond had actually been
going under a pseudonym for this
particular scam he was known as Charles
Martin again this is the same kind of
thing that he told Martha that he was in
the import-export business and he was
very successful yada yada so um so he
basically had kind of been grooming this
one particular for a while and since
they had killed this one woman they're
like okay well she lives in Grand Rapids
so we're just gonna go to Grand Rapids
and we'll just kind of like turn up
there and get that scam working so um so
they write to Delphine and you know she
says okay sure come on out here and he's
like hey is it okay if I bring my sister
Martha and she said fine so she kind of
like so Raymond and Delphine get into a
sexual relationship um Martha obviously
did not like this very much um the funny
thing about this and like I said a lot
of this assisted him a long time ago so
a lot of this I guess is from like later
reports of later you know things that
people said at the trial
apparently Delphine had been [ __ ]
this guy for a while but she didn't know
that he wore a hairpiece because he was
kind of bald and he had that big scar on
his head yeah like from the head injury
and apparently she walked in the
bathroom one morning and like saw him
without his hairpiece and she's like and
apparently that cooled her on the whole
well because she thought that he was
being deceptive I think that's what it
was I don't think it was just like oh my
god what a
I think I think it was just kind of like
well you know you didn't tell me any of
this before hand so she was like shocked
yeah he couldn't tell that must've been
a hell of a hairpiece I guess it won't
maybe back in those days you didn't
really maybe you didn't think of it I
don't have to do that kind of [ __ ] I
guess not
I've never seen a hairpiece that
convinced me yeah yeah so this is this
is [ __ ] up today's version of the hair
piece is just a [ __ ] shave all that
[ __ ] off and [ __ ] [ __ ] grow a foo
Manchu mustache that [ __ ] around here
like that yeah that's today's hair piece
well like I said I do feel like it
probably it looks better look just
[ __ ] ball just be involved it's good
I mean depending on what your head looks
like some people don't look at look at
bald but it's like it's also you know
what else it depends on your [ __ ]
your [ __ ] musculature yeah a big
muscular guy bald [ __ ] looks a lot
better than a fat [ __ ] who's
bald or like a real fit a real thin real
good tall thin look at the rock yeah
I don't consider the rock to be a bald
guy yeah they're fun to have you here
he's bald as [ __ ] well it's you don't
consider a guy bald unless they have
like the classic like middle-aged man
wearing of hair yeah but you look at
[ __ ] yeah I like when I think of the
rock I kind of forget that he's bald
yeah he doesn't come across as a Baga
yeah look at that [ __ ] Bob oh yeah
he's bald [ __ ] but when you're that big
he's just you still just handsome as
[ __ ] yeah that's a handsome [ __ ] man
I'm an expression man crush and lock
crazy on [ __ ] a rock I saw him on
that Jumanji that last one challenge e2
there was a good movie you guys haven't
seen that and I'm looking to rock I'm
going mad being a rocker same eh that
muffler looks so much better than me man
yeah he's good luck guy he's it yeah
he's like he's giant he's gigantic he's
a [ __ ] warrior
yeah yeah he's like some kind of
Polynesian right I think so yeah yeah
you know good yeah he does he's yeah
he's like a very large that's the only
non-white guy that could be Superman to
me Superman always caught you know
[ __ ] Christopher Reeves this [ __ ]
Superman
I can't yeah it's hard for me to see
anyone yeah Superman and then you have
this some of these [ __ ] new new
people you know in the scene they're all
like well you can race swap Indian
anything you know I mean Superman is a
fake character he can be any color no
[ __ ] Superman is Jewish you got to
read between the [ __ ] lines that is
the kid who drew Superman and came up
with that was a Jewish kid run from
[ __ ] Germany yeah
running from the Nazis the homeland
destroyed and he's a now a new Superman
in the new world to save mankind yeah he
goes back to all that it is a Jewish
story in the name call el and jor-el and
all that this authors are all having to
do with the canoe deism you know that
comes from el yeah God you know sky god
it's a sky god although I would argue
that if you have a fictional character
after a certain point in time it's kind
of like particularly when it's popular
Superman it's not really your character
anymore so it's like people can like do
different spins on it you can but I know
deep in my heart that Superman's Jewish
yeah he's he's and he's like a an
idealized Jewish character kind of that
damn greco-roman he's Greco kind of
[ __ ] Greek [ __ ] statue face pale
skin black hair you know the man [ __ ]
he's is a mixture of [ __ ] you know
super strong a super smart and good
harder than [ __ ] it is a Jewish
character into himself yeah no I'm just
saying that it's like but after a
certain but the only not the only
non-white and you say what's up loud
Jews go I'm not white yeah whatever dude
you know that mean [ __ ] I know what I
see the only non-white person that could
ever be Superman and haven't people in
the in the [ __ ] audience might agree
to disagree on give a [ __ ] the rock
could play super bad yeah hell yeah
what is what you could tell I'm drunk
when are we going on to a side this is
you know I haven't even got through the
first honey he's got to the first case I
keep going through his skin so that's
what I mean it's like this is what it's
like we have to go soon it's like
I might call I was gonna do I was gonna
do four sets of couples now I might have
now I might only have to do two because
it's not gonna keep going off all these
sand rocks and I can't I can't even get
through one case I can't even get
through that been quiet for a long time
though I came to get though so um yeah
so where was I okay so like I said so
she so delphine gets mad at seeing his
baldness and it's like you know hey you
misrepresented yourself um you know
Martha is is kind of like she's still
pissed off about this cuz they're having
sex and everything but it's like she's
kind of like seeing how this is gonna
play out
she told Delphine hey why don't you take
some sleeping pills to chill out which
Delphine did which okay um so Delphine
like goes to sleep I guess and then she
had a baby like I said she had a
two-year-old kid named Bray now raynelle
starts to cry and Martha picks up the
kid and starts choking her yeah you know
this is a two year old girl right so she
picks her up starts choking her because
she's making too much noise
now Raymond says hey you know if
Delphine wakes up and sees what you're
doing she's gonna go to the police and
were busted so Martha says we'll do
something about it so Raymond basically
goes in the room gets a gun and shoots
Delphine in the head while she's
sleeping right in front of the
two-year-old kid who is like just
sitting there damn
so thank god this is her kid right no
this is Delphine's kid this is the
victim okay yes I'm saying yeah there's
our kid yeah
Jonathan damn yeah although that kids -
I mean yeah well they're more worse [ __ ]
is gonna happen okay so so they rap
Delphine's body up take it down to the
basement um you know they dig a hole cuz
I guess the basement in this place had a
dirt floor so they you know kind of
covered it up then covered the grave
with cement so they're in this house
there's a body in the basement that they
have buried and put cement over they
still have the two-year-old girl she is
still there
she obviously
was upset because she didn't know where
her mother was she wouldn't eat she kept
crying all the time you know so [ __ ]
Raymond and Martha they like looted the
house they took all the valuables they
like took all those woman's money and
[ __ ] like that
then finally Raymond's after two days
he's kind of tells Martha he's like okay
well we have to get rid of this kid
right so Martha didn't want to do it but
after a while she's kind of like well
what else am I gonna do it's like she's
already been party to a couple of
murders it's like she's afraid that he's
gonna leave her and all this other kind
of crap so basically he took like a
[ __ ] tub and filled it up with water
and she drowned the kid in it damp and
then buried the kid he made her do it
yeah in the basement and she did it mmm
so they drowned a baby yeah and buried
it next to the mother [ __ ] out yeah
and the shitty tea these people are
awesome right and it's like ask so after
they did that cause you know what they
did after they do that they went to the
movies oh yeah try to forget about it
they won't go see a movie you got some
popcorn [ __ ] like that sat there
watching a [ __ ] movie holy crap man
so these two [ __ ] get back from the
movies and apparently good on their
neighbors because the neighbors had
gotten suspicious because they heard I
guess like some weird noise or something
like that coming from next door so they
called the cops so when Martha and
Raymond got back from the movies there
were cops on their doorstep
now they they got questioned now it
seems like since they I guess they knew
that they had left a lot of evidence
behind they didn't really seem like they
had covered their tracks all that well
so pretty much as soon as they got
arrested they pretty much alike yeah we
did that [ __ ] and land fast you know
what I mean yeah so really entirely sure
why now what they were trying to do
because they got caught in Michigan they
were actually thought that if they
confessed in Michigan then they would
get put in prison there because they
wanted to be in prison in Michigan
because there was no death penalty like
they didn't want to get sent back to New
York to like to be extradited to New
York because they had the death penalty
still and so they were trying to like
kind of wangle
way out of it because Martha was like
she didn't want to get put in the
electric chair or whatever so they gave
them like a lot of stories about how hey
if you cooperate and that's not the
other thing like you'll get out of it so
basically they pretty much just you know
gave everything up and said what they
had been up to um you know not
surprisingly the press dubbed this the
Lonely Hearts murder case since that was
how they found most of their victims
also not surprisingly the press really
leaned in hard on calling Martha fat so
um you know what I mean sold newspapers
it did yeah and and everything you know
I guess it had like a lot of really
salacious details in the sense that you
know here is like a couple they weren't
legally married but they were kind of
like a couple and we're going around
preying on other women so there was like
a lot of you know speculation about like
who's sleeping with what and was there
threesomes and all this other kind of
[ __ ] plus like I said because Martha was
overweight you know they called her
stuff like big Martha and the giggling
divorcee and two hundred a 200-pound
figure of Wrath led one of the [ __ ]
papers so they said pretty much
everything that was written about them
at this time like had to mention like
how fat she was and some of them had
some said she weighed like 300 pounds
simply it wasn't it was more like 230
pounds yeah which is still a lot but
it's like you know I mean she had a
glandular condition so um yeah so there
was this whole thing where even though
Raymond he had been like kind of
reluctant to get involved with Martha
right because it's like when she first
like turned up and he found out she
didn't have as much money and he was
just kind of like yeah bye and he like
took off but then she kind of like
chased after him and followed him and
then he was like okay well you can be my
accomplice or whatever so I don't really
know how into her he was like I think
they did have a sexual relationship and
she was obviously very jealous like
every time they you know found another
victim and stuff but I don't know but it
seems really weird like once they were
both convicted which they were um he
kind of went on on about how much he
loved
after and blob what he was like trying
to protect her and all this other kind
of stuff I don't know it's like maybe he
was just trying to be like she's trying
to look sympathetic he was just yeah I
think he was just trying to be like not
a monster type of thing so you know the
whole [ __ ] thing about the trial it
was like this big huge [ __ ] circus
about an everything at all for her yeah
it did and it seemed like and they and
and she was like the same with him just
like oh I would have done anything for
him and yada yada so it was kind of like
this whole thing where he was like
trying to get her off he's like oh I'll
confess to this if you guys let her go
and blah - blah um so like I said he did
like confess to pretty much everything
and she backed the [ __ ] story up so
basically you know like I said there was
this huge [ __ ] deal at the trial they
both you know testified on their own
behalf and everything they tried to
paint themselves as more sympathetic but
apparently it didn't work the jury for a
while it took him a while like to go
through the deliberation because 11 of
them were just like yeah [ __ ] hang
I'm widget sad oh I don't even want to
deal with it um but one of one of the
jurors was kind of like um he wasn't
sure about Martha's mental state and
maybe she wasn't as culpable as he was
and all this other stuff so there was
like a lot of arguing going on there but
apparently the other 11 jurors finally
convinced him it's like look can we just
like not and we're just gonna get rid of
all these people so they were actually
both sentenced to death
so as afraid as she was of the electric
chair she did actually end up going to
the electric chair the crazy thing about
this was that I didn't know that they
used to do this I thought that if you
had it was your day to go to the chair
or whatever that was like only you liked
your day but apparently they
electrocuted raymond fernandes
and martha back on the same day and
there were two other criminals convicted
on that same day - like before like in
the morning like they're like okay well
we'll fry this guy and then this guy and
they're gonna lined up ready yeah and
it's like I was like that's messed up
it's like you know what I mean it well
it makes sense that way you have their
braids there to do it you have all the
[ __ ] equipment you need the presses I
mean
like a fish once I know it's [ __ ] up
yeah but it's like yeah that definitely
does seem like a more I'm I was just
like I I guess I never heard of that
happening before cuz usually when you
hear about you know because if you're on
death row it usually takes so long like
to go through the process that it's
usually just like one guy and it's like
that's his day if you're gonna fire up
old Sparky man [ __ ] you know take take
a bunch of people out at once I guess
that but yeah this was a day of it yeah
I mean it it's like it was just so weird
to me to read that it was just like a
detail that stuck out so this is like
it's saying saying by the way where they
both got [ __ ] where they both got
electrocuted so yeah they were both
electrocuted for their [ __ ] crimes
and probably rightfully so because this
really does seem like like I said this
is another case where probably their
pasts you know his head injury obviously
seemed to contribute quite a bit to the
man he became later on because by all
accounts he was you know a normal dude
like before that happened and then
afterwards like he had completely his
personality had completely changed and
she seemed to have not only the
glandular problem that made her
overweight which made her the target of
bullying but also you know sexual
molestation by her family it does seem
like she didn't have the best family
life and it does seem like she had a lot
of like self-loathing that would make
her susceptible to someone coming along
like this naturally yeah and it does it
definitely does seem like that but I
found this like really interesting this
dynamic between the two of them it's
like it's really kind of like a sad
[ __ ] story man and said for the
victims as well because it's like all
these women that had written into these
[ __ ] you know Lonely Hearts columns
like kind of hoping to find some dude
that would love them and then this
[ __ ] do shows up and with his
girlfriend and just like hey I'm gonna
take all your money they're gonna beat
you in the head with a hammer and kill
your kid by that's like [ __ ] this is
like horrible those dads were always
sketchy
even back back in the 70s and 80s one I
know it's like the Craigslist of the
1940s no good ever comes of it and well
and even back then people knew that
because like I said the one woman that
they killed Janet Fay it's like even her
family had been like hey mate maybe
don't like answer ads from that because
it's like that's some sketchy but so
even back then like people knew that
remember back in the 80s and 90s had
those damn dating services where it was
kind like a video-rental Club where
dudes that make people would make videos
of themselves oh yeah I remember seeing
commercials for that man they have a ha
they have like a whole genre of videos
of all that [ __ ] that's leaked over the
time from the 80s
well yeah go see him how cringy that
[ __ ] was yeah I had no idea that a
dating services were that cringey but
was [ __ ] ridiculous
guys putting on big old peacock shows
and saying ridiculous [ __ ] trying to get
women to date that big [ __ ] dress it
up and it's all [ __ ] like losers it's
like sad sacks of [ __ ] I was just
watching a video this morning that just
came up in my recommended feed yeah and
it was a guy that was making fun of a
pickup artist like a video of a pickup
pickup artists like convention are like
a class yeah but I guess I guess people
pay for classes like that yeah I've seen
those it is like and so this guy was
like making fun of it and this like
class it was hilarious because I guess
the girl she had a girl there and I
guess that they had paid her to be there
as like the victim or whatever so like
this guy forget yeah so the guy could
like show off his like technique yeah
and it's funny because apparently even
though she got paid to be there she was
not having it and she just like
basically just called we got a creep to
his face and she just laughed at him and
it's just like it was really really
funny and at one point she even like
turn to the audience's like are you guys
learning anything I'm so down down it's
just like you know you can't look at me
to tell you people okay dudes out there
it's hilarious I've had some
good-looking girlfriends my EE all you
got is just look at my [ __ ] feeds in
my life and finish it you know Jenni can
attest Jenny's a beautiful [ __ ] girl
another but not women I went out with
nothing but good-looking women I'm not a
pickup artist not at all it was easy
because I was just acting like myself
and I wasn't really looking for anything
and they come to you and you become
friends with them you can't really you
can pick up certain kind of girls in the
way that I've seen those little things
you know like those demonstrations and
those you don't want that one yeah if
you can pick her up that way you don't
want her oh yeah because she's obviously
she's got motors she's got a roll murder
that's it okay well in that also she's
got her own motors too that's not how it
goes down you go into a scene you make a
good reputation for yourself you're
friends with everybody and they
gravitate towards you
well I think that what a lot of dudes
don't and this is actually it's kind of
sad yes yeah it's kind of sad because
one I feel like these type of insel
dudes that would pay for this type of
class yeah you've already lost not only
your money you've lost your dignity
you've lost any chance of getting a
woman to ever love you you know what I
mean I'm just saying that I think the
problem is they see women as a different
species almost or that there's some like
trick you can do to like tap into our
brains or something I'm not really sure
where they're coming from also a lot of
them seem like they're just like a hair
away from being rapists which is a
little scary but also they don't really
seem to see women as just a person with
the same feelings as them or the same
like they don't really seem to see it
like that they just see they're very
goal-oriented and I don't think that's a
good you're just using that person as an
object to get what you have you don't
care what they want they used to have
some YouTube show YouTube channel used
to watch it was [ __ ] hilarious it was
some guy from India and he was kind of
like a pickup artist and he was in I
think it was India I didn't Pakistan a
seashell yeah India Pakistan he goes
into Europe and he's like [ __ ]
picking up he's got a him stuff on video
picking up all these damn European girls
uh-huh using a bunch of damn flim-flam
and stuff you know that's not that's not
really he was really doing it I think
although you could fake that pretty a
fake that's not real life and that's not
that's not really how it goes down women
see through everything you do if you're
man women see through it yeah we're a
lot smarter than you just stop it if the
woman a woman falls for that [ __ ] cuz
she has ulterior motives right
women are also predators yes we are so
that's it that's something dude so don't
seem to understand we have our own
reasons you can't shirt women they
[ __ ] see a dot guy Commons don't even
[ __ ] try [ __ ] that's what I mean
you can only work with women you can't
trick them if you think you're tricking
a woman yes you were tricking yourself
we know every every single woman with
this dude and everything she was getting
something that she didn't have she could
probably saw herself as [ __ ]
conniving him she may not have you but
you know what people have different
points of view but no do you know what
this guy was trying to do like I know I
know all about negging I know what that
is where you could like go up and like
it kind of like low-key like backhanded
compliment slash insult a woman and then
that's supposed to like knock her value
down so she feels like she has to
impress you something like that so his
first thing was he asked her what would
you rather have OCD or ADHD that was
like his opening pick-up line I think if
somebody was at a bar like and I've had
some like really sad like pickup
attempts before in bars um but if
somebody came up to me in a bar and said
that I think I would just like look at
that and if they like persistent and
like talking to me I think I would just
hit him in the face
me and jenni would be hanging out this
is before we were a couple we'd be
hanging out and dudes to come up and try
to [ __ ] do these lines on her and
she'd look at me and we just are
snickering how beautiful that [ __ ] was
it's like it's the saddest [ __ ] show
ever and I might've been it and it
wasn't and it wasn't any kind of thing
low down like we were I might have been
I might have had a girlfriend at that
time yeah and it was just honest she's
looking at me and I'm look at her like
that where the [ __ ] is a douche he said
that damn some of the shit's funny I
mean like a few times I've been in
situations where I thought to myself
like one time I one time I was at a club
and I think I I think we were together
at this point but I think you were in
the bathroom or you were like talking to
somebody or something and I was like and
I was in the front and like I got
surrounded by four guys yeah and that
scared me a little bit because I was
just kind of like because I therefore
that um well like I just said you were
in the bathroom or you were so I don't
know where you were there were some
times where we weren't together but I
still kind of had a protector I have to
shoo dudes away well it's these four
guys like and I'm just like sitting
there smoke cuz I used to smoke back
then but I so I'm just sitting there
smoking either was waiting for you
actually yeah and I'm just like sitting
there and these four got let and they're
like surrounding me like this and I'm
like oh [ __ ] here we go and like um I
think and basically I was just like you
know [ __ ] off I don't feel like I could
possess I don't I don't like try to be
nice to do this dude just come up and
there's like hey I'm just like yeah [ __ ]
off I don't want to talk to you because
that seems to be the only thing that
they understand Andy but even then you
have to watch because a lot of them will
get very hostile and that's kind of what
happened in this situation and there
were four of them like I was like
basically like man [ __ ] off I don't want
to talk to you I'm waiting for somebody
I think and they would not leave and I'm
like seriously art look at my face I was
like leave I do not want to talk to you
and they would not leave so jenny was
only gonna go out with like some cool
goth dudes from the scene who were
already well-established he's his friend
and [ __ ] just can't come up and
do that there was times where I was just
like no dude if I can get you [ __ ] out
here cuz I you know I mean youyou
remember what that guy think what would
I have in common with it like then get
the [ __ ] out what would I have in common
with a person is you know what I mean
it's like you don't know anything about
me you don't know anything it's like
what you just see boobs or you see a guy
because there is a certain type of
normal dude yeah like frat boy type dude
that has like a goth chick fetish we see
it a lot yeah and and we are very over
goth girls see that a mile away well
it's very common I mean I have had that
I've had that happen like even when I
was like fat and ugly like back in the
old days you were never well like you
know so I had that haven't I was younger
it's like you get like frat dudes it's
like they see a chick with like you know
black hair and like gothy clothes on and
it's like a fetish type of thing or they
think that you're a [ __ ] I'm not sure
how many's combination of both things
but yeah so probably we should take a
break it's gonna go on for a long time
here's the thing like we were talking
about this earlier I had actually I was
gonna do like four cases on this show
I'm going on but since we have already
gone on so long I think I'm just gonna
cut two out and we'll just like do two
so when we go back I don't know where
she gets this [ __ ] because what we did
four cases on the other validation Kim
do it real quick a case is about two
hours or two and a half hours you said
four and I'm thinking women is gonna be
eight hours show to cover a real case is
two hours I'd save that [ __ ] for another
show did you want to go out tonight or
what
yeah we probably all right so we'll do
one more case when we come back from the
break I'll try to keep it like shorter
than this one and hopefully we won't go
off on as many tangents as we did this
tonight he's talking so I can actually I
said we I said we an didn't just say you
putting this [ __ ] on even though it's
mostly we'll talk about one more case
when we come back from the break and
hopefully I don't leave some [ __ ] out
but yeah it's like you know as long as
we have like a few hours worth of cosmos
we've got a like a three hour show is
good sorry
it's [ __ ] fine yeah so we are going
to take a break and when we come back we
will talk about yet another killer
couple on our Valentine's Day special so
we will be back in just a few minutes
hey baby are you hiding from the vacuum
cleaner yeah it can't get you up there I
promise for a little girl she always
hides up there when daddy runs the
vacuum cleaner
she's afraid it's gonna eat her Oh on
top of mommy's desk
they're gonna be a battle for the cat
tree
you can try and get up there Pook
Beijing's and your boom what are you
gonna do what are you gonna do what's up
what's up
Beijing's I am in it
no you love true crime
I love true crime and I've spent the
last three years compiling a series of
the most intriguing unsolved murders of
the 20th century it's called the
faceless villain and volume three is
available now featuring such fascinating
cases as the Caddy murders the carry
baby's case the Frog Boys the al-qasr
murders and the inokashira park
dismemberment incident the faithless
villain volume three is an involving
exploration of unsolved slang spanning
the years from 1980 to 1999 pick up your
copy and print or eBook formats on
Amazon or download the audiobook version
from audible.com and get ready for a
chilling journey through modern crime
history
all right we are back from the break on
this Valentine's Day special as I said
earlier I was actually planning on
covering four different couples on the
show and had notes to match however
because we are going on for such a damn
long time I decided to cut it short
we'll just talk about one more couple on
this show and hopefully the show isn't
like five hours long the shoot well you
know I never know how shits gonna go so
I always like to have like a lot of
units in case those other cases we can
do on another Valentine's Day we'll have
to do the research already yeah that's
true although by the time next year
comes four will make them regular shows
you could make them regular shows too I
could yeah I could do like a different
thing so let's talk about this other
case as I said I cut out a couple of the
ones but let's keep this one because
this was a [ __ ] doozy this is the
case of David and Catherine Bernie now
this is the very rare case of a serial
killer couple like husband-and-wife
serial killing team this was from Perth
Western Australia and most of their
crimes occurred in the mid to late 1980s
so let's talk a little bit about their
childhoods and then how they ended up
meeting each other and [ __ ] like that
so David Birney was actually the oldest
of six children his parents were
actually very poor kind of lived in
squalor they were both also alcoholics
and for much of their childhood him in
his siblings childhood they were kind of
taken away from their parents
periodically by you know the Australian
equivalent of Child Protective Services
so you know not a great home life there
by the time that the murders occurred
apparently David Bernie's mother was
living in the this horrible like
apartment that was like it's just
covered with dust and grime and no one
ever cleaned anything or anything like
that
his dad also died in 1986 now
David actually had met Kathryn who would
later become his partner in serial
killing crime when they were both
children because they lived next door to
one another um Kathryn's home life when
she was a child was also not super happy
her mom died when she was a baby she was
less than a year old and she was
actually sent to live with her father in
South Africa when she was two years old
she was sent back to Australia and she
moved in with her grandparents now she
was
of a kid where apparently she was I
don't know if it was because the death
of her mother because that was just like
her personality type or anything like
that but she was like um very uh kind of
like sad not a real like outgoing child
or anything like that and for whatever
reason I guess maybe because she was
poor maybe she seemed like kind of a
bummer
um other kids in the neighborhood were
kind of like not allowed to play with
her so she was kind of like a loner um
you know so that's kind of how that one
so the two of them like I said they kind
of you know made an acquaintance as
children as kind of two like-minded
lonely people and then they kind of like
drifted apart but they actually ended up
meeting again in their late teens now in
the meantime David had already had a lot
of like juvenile offenses you know
mostly minor [ __ ] now in the early 1960s
he looked like he might actually kind of
maybe be along the lines of just maybe
getting a career or a job or something
like that he started training as an
apprentice jockey however um like a
horse jockey yeah like a horse jockey
now he apparently enjoyed it but I guess
and I've seen like in ER of like I've
watched a documentary about these two
and they talked to some people that
worked at the stable I guess where he
worked and they said yeah it's like he
was real they they basically just gave
him a job to give him a job because I
guess as a kid he was kind of like real
thin and like sickly and stuff and they
did he must have been tiny yeah so they
didn't think that he would do what
although when I've seen pictures of him
when he was an adult he looked like
pretty regular sized okay maybe even a
little bit the United States
professional horse jockeys are tired you
have to be really really yeah yes what
is lighter the better what's funny is
that they even have their who being in
the whole team coming from out of the
horse industry you know my family and
everything but they also have their own
groupies there's a certain group II that
goes after the dam five foot tall or 4
foot 11 [ __ ] 80 pound [ __ ] dudes
yeah yeah well I can see that they're
not 80 yes and maybe someone might be 80
but yeah it was like 80 pounds that'd be
pretty someone might be about a hundred
pounds or ten pounds a little bit guys
yeah I can see how you might be into
that how some people well they they make
a lot of money to they're like a
professional
racecar driver but that's not like
everything um money is power
it is you have the power to change a
woman's life if she doesn't come from
anything then you know that's true yeah
but I you know I don't know it's kind of
like a thing where I however rich the
dude is it's like if he was like really
horrible yeah like I don't think it
would be some of those douchebags that
pull up in the [ __ ] Ferraris and [ __ ]
you know I mean yeah it's like you don't
have to like get up and see that in your
face every day
I don't think so especially someone
especially here in United States a lot
of them come from countries where
[ __ ] the money doesn't mean anything
anyway to them they're born with him
[ __ ] you know I'm talking about well
it's you know I just don't think maybe
it'd be worth it in the short term but
it's like how you have to put up with
like every day I don't know if any
amount of money with those dudes music
man there's not one woman in their life
there's [ __ ] 100 of them well yeah
because that's what they do they
overcompensate yeah well yeah so
apparently like the people that worked
at this staple said you know he might
have made a good jockey if he had kind
of like applied himself and everything
like that but apparently even funny when
he was a teenager he decided that maybe
he'd rather be a criminal I guess so
he actually ended up getting fired from
this you know stable or the jockey
program wherever or wherever when it was
alleged that he had I mean I guess this
old guy that owned a boarding house
David had like smashed their head in and
took their money so like I said he was
already kind of starting very early now
apparently when this happened um David
and Kathryn were still hanging out not
sure if they were like a couple at this
point but they were friends at this time
so Kathryn did know about all of his
like criminal activities and apparently
either approved of them or helped him
out with them so this is kind of one of
the rare cases where I don't think it
was kind of like you know a woman that
just kind of like got sucked into this
yeah I think she was kind of a little
bit like that too you know I mean
because it started like from a pretty
young age so they both of them after
this happened after he got fired from
the stable like they both kind of went
off on this little like crime spree you
know
robbery and [ __ ] yeah it is a little bit
like that except a lot more [ __ ] up
they actually ended up getting arrested
in June of 1969 and they got convicted
of 11 counts of breaking and entering
and you know theft so they at this stage
I think Katherine was pregnant but by
someone else not him
they also admitted that they had stolen
like a bunch of like an ox acetylene
torch and they had tried to like break
into a safe at a drive-in theater like
the drive-in theater and it did I don't
know so since she was pregnant she got
put on probation David went to jail for
nine months now a month later I guess
they were convicted of some other like
they they had some other like charges
pending
they actually pleaded guilty to those
David ended up getting three years added
to his sentence and Katherine got put on
probation again for another four years
now in June of 1970 David breaks out of
the prison that he was in and finds
Katherine again they got caught a little
less than a month later and got 53
counts stealing receiving stolen
property breaking and entering various
other things unlawfully driving motor
vehicles unlawfully using vehicles it's
like all these different petty [ __ ] yeah
now when police searched through their
stuff they found they had a whole bunch
of different clothes a whole bunch of
different wigs they had some like food
they had stolen radios like they had a
hundred sticks of gel ignite a hundred
and twenty detonators yeah and three
fuses yeah so I'm not sure what exactly
they were planning on blowing up but
they were clearly planning on blowing up
something probably add these weird
delusions like blowing up safes and
blowing walls that's kinda when I felt
like the kind of stuff that they're
talking about is usually used to like
blow up stuff blowing stumps out of the
ground and I think they thought they
were Bonnie and Clyde yes point you know
and I'm
like they're going around the country
like it was some kind of romantic thing
we're gonna go around blowing up safes
and yeah there's gonna be like criminals
they come get me copper I feel like it
was that good yeah blown-up safes
doesn't work yeah yeah cracking safes
that's something else but blowing him up
now so basically she said so they get
all this muck and they get all these
charges against them Katherine has gone
a record as saying at this particular
trial that you know her and David they
were like in love and she would do
anything for him and stuff like that
which what apparently turned out to be
true later on at this stage David gets
sentenced to two and a half years in
prison Katherine only gets six months
now she had the baby at this point but
it was taken away from her by the
welfare you know workers and they held
onto it for her until she got out um now
at this point because David was in jail
and she had got out and she had a new
baby it almost seemed like at this stage
she might have had a normal life because
she was away from him for a while she
had a kid then she actually went and got
a job she got a job as like a live-in
nanny for this one family so when she
was like working as a nanny the son of
the family whose name was Donald
mcLaughlin he fell in love with her and
asked her to marry him so they got
married in 1972 and she was 21 at this
point and they would end up having a
further six children together so she had
one kid by somebody else I don't think
it was David I think it was some other
dude that had knocked her up but that
but her and her husband Donald ended up
having like six children together and it
did like seem like [ __ ] was gonna be
normal for a time because like I said at
this point David Birney was still in
jail however and some people have can
have said that then I watched a
documentary about these two and somebody
pointed out this was probably like a big
turning point the little the first
little boy that she had who's name was
little Donny like after his father he
was I think he was only six months old
or seven months old
and he was like someone was at their
house visiting them and the little kid
was in the driveway and someone backed
over him with the car and she and it
happened like right in front of her
killed her so yes so she saw her baby
get run over in the driveway of her
house and everybody said that that like
messed her up big time as it would which
is understandable so even though these
two were married for a long time it
wasn't a super happy marriage at some
point the husband became unemployed they
had six kids Catherines dad and uncle
also ended up moving in there with them
and she kind of had to take care of all
of these people um unsurprisingly she
just said [ __ ] it and she didn't want to
clean the house anymore but she and I
can't blame her for that they didn't
have a lot of money so it was kind of
like not a good situation now it turned
out that David had got out of jail in
the interim and for two years her and
David actually had an illicit adulterous
affair while she was married to this
another person then finally she was just
like forget it I'm just like getting out
of this marriage so she called her
husband and said okay well I'm getting
back together with David so bye take
Carrie [ __ ] so so she moved this back in
with David Birney they had been apart at
this stage for thirteen years you know
now they never actually married
officially but I guess there's a thing
where um she actually ended up taking
his last name so I guess they were like
common-law married so it's like I know
they have that like some states and like
some this is Australia you know I push
in that me and you at this point
well Florida does not have common though
they don't know some states do because
my my sister used to live in Colorado
and I think they are seven years and so
her and her husband were common-law
married but even though they did
officially do it later but they're not
married anymore but they were all those
only haven't you mentioned no I just
know that because you know for various
things if some states do have it like
it's usually seven years but um yeah but
Florida does have it so she actually
ended up changing her name to his last
name now there is a lot of weird [ __ ]
going on in this household from the very
beginning now David Birney apparently
had one of those and you see this in a
lot of serial killers also had a
sexually insatiable like an insatiable
sexual appetite eBay
simply had to have sex several times a
day I always wanted variety [ __ ] like
that said he had like the house full of
porn apparently his younger brother who
ended up staying with the couple for a
while like he was in prison too so it's
not a happy family like I said the
brother was actually in prison for
indecently interfering with his
six-year-old niece and he later told the
authorities that the six-year-old led
him on yes she did it yes yeah yeah so
you can see what kind of people you're
dealing with here he blames her yeah
what she did and this is the brother of
the series right he's so like I said
this is like this is this is a real
situation yes so this brother ends up
after he gets out of prison he didn't
have anywhere to go so he ends up going
and staying with with David and
Catherine now so the brother whose name
was James he said that you know even
though he was no winner either he said
David wasn't super great it's like they
had all these like fights it's like they
weren't that David and Catherine weren't
real happy about him being there like
David threatened to kill him on several
occasions he also said that David was
super super into kinky sex had a huge
like porn collection
said he had to have sex four or five
times a day and this is kind of special
and I'm don't really want to know how he
knew this but the brother said I saw him
use a hypodermic of that stuff you have
when they're going to put stitches in
your legs so like an anaesthetic it
makes you numb he put the needle in his
penis then he had sex David has had many
women he always has someone so he's like
put an anaesthetic like injecting he's
anesthetic watch his brother do this
yes so the younger brother is saying
that he saw this happen I'm like so
that's a weird [ __ ] yeah so apparently
this kind of [ __ ] wasn't doing it for
David anymore so in 1986 David and
Catherine decided that they're going to
start killing people because that's the
next thing you do I guess yeah
apparently they had done everything
that they wanted to do together and now
they're looking for some new excitement
it's gonna spice up the relationship by
going and [ __ ] murdering innocent
people yeah so you know especially happy
Valentine's Day yes so that's how
they're gonna do it so they so these two
like I said this is not a situation
where one of them was being led on by
the other one this one it just really
seems like they were both super into
this [ __ ] and they were just kind of
like egging each other on because
apparently they both knew what the score
was they're both sitting there talking
about how are we gonna kidnap these
girls how we gonna rape these girls how
we gonna get rid of the bodies they like
figured all this [ __ ] out ahead of time
right he actually told her that he's he
tells Katherine it's like you were gonna
get super intense orgasms by watching me
[ __ ] another woman who was bound and
gagged at like raping another woman that
you're gonna super get off on that and
she was like yeah sounds legit yeah yeah
yeah of course so that's how I got
buying that [ __ ] but that was that's
what he sold her that's what he sold her
and she bought it
apparently knowing like I said these are
intensely messed up people so October
6th 1986 there's a 22 year old student
Mary Nielsen she turns up at their house
um to buy some tires for her color
because apparently he was selling some
now she had actually I guess she knew
someone that worked with David Birney or
she worked she was a co-worker I'm not
really sure but she's like well he she
knew that he had like some spare parts
and she's like hey I need some tires we
can you give me a dealing and some tires
and he's like yes of course I can do
that so yes
so she turns up at the house just to buy
some [ __ ] tires like you do so not um
surprisingly she disappeared
now she was like like I said none of the
victims and I and I hate to say this
because I feel like a lot of serial
killers will target you know prostitutes
or something like that because it's
easier to get away with it I guess David
and Kathryn Bernie all of their victims
as far as I can determine were pretty
well they were all like middle to
upper-class they were all like college
students or things like that so these
were people that
would I mean immediately be reported
missing you know what I mean because
link was trying to sell this to his old
lady like this just gonna be really
exciting you're gonna [ __ ] love to
see this [ __ ]
guarantee that [ __ ] was like watching a
possum [ __ ] a possum molest a damn rag
doll I bet you have a [ __ ] why do I feel
like that's just not absolutely how it
turns out because see the thing about
that type of [ __ ] not sex is that it's
always like way better in your head yeah
it looks it was way better in his head I
bet you do watch that [ __ ] you'd be like
that was some lame [ __ ] dude yeah I
wonder if I guess not because she kept
doing this [ __ ] I said maybe she did get
off on it no she didn't I don't know I
doubt it if they did they had a very low
threshold they couldn't run in our
circle take down
what was that Club we used to go to
[ __ ] well you know these are very
like conventional yeah I guess people
know they weren't even good look in
these [ __ ] they never are that's the
thing yeah so yes so their victim Mary
was actually last seen leaving a shop in
October yeah they're coming out southern
Knights yeah it's a gay club but they
did like a fetish night yeah I don't
think they do it wasn't even a gay club
that was a [ __ ] club yeah but they had
a good [ __ ] [ __ ] you know what we had
it they had a goth night there goth
industrial and I we used to me and Jenny
used to go yeah they did like fetishes
let's stop a friend of ours used to run
it with Dustin Dustin yeah Dustin ran
the [ __ ] night we had our own night
there it was just [ __ ] fun night it
was yeah nothing but [ __ ] pretty
people up in that [ __ ] yeah yeah
and the shows were funny
yeah and someone were porn stars yeah
yeah you know you never could tell what
was gonna happen down there and that was
just our scene that really it was open
to the public but the public didn't know
about it yeah because I feel like every
now and then you get somebody but it
wasn't downtown so it wasn't like
somewhere you'd get it's somewhere you
had to drive to yeah it wasn't somewhere
that you would just walk in like as it
wasn't in a walking area mm-hm
but uh yeah so yeah I have some
interesting pictures of us from they had
me now damn cat box that's right and see
that's why I didn't know
why you didn't know what a [ __ ]
litter box cake was because I'm like
what do you think that was that I took
the pictures of you eating out of that's
yeah essentially what that was they had
a show had a show going all these
contests and [ __ ] they had this fake
[ __ ] cat litter box it was just a
[ __ ] cat litter box filled with
[ __ ] Coco Puffs rolls and rice rice
krispies and it looks gross though yeah
and chocolate pudding in there yeah
like cash it and [ __ ] head to eat
through there as fast as you could yeah
to find something I want some prizes
yeah you would win stuff when like you
know you like bar gift cards or like it
handcuffs or it was always like fetishy
stuff I think I won some porn yeah we
got like a porn dvd oh yeah I think I
want some handcuffs there one time and I
want some other [ __ ] that went on for a
little while that was a good that was a
good Club it's [ __ ] fun I remember
having to like one of the contests I
don't even remember what it was I was so
[ __ ] up but it's I I remember having
to like stick like a well not like in
her butt but like we went yeah well no
they were giving you these [ __ ] they
were these giant like inflatable penises
yeah and then like you had to like
pretend to stick him in someone's butt
you weren't really sick and when they're
brought off yeah they were just like a
balloon or something
a long time yeah that was a couple years
back but these [ __ ] could only dream
of this yeah we were actually [ __ ]
doing that [ __ ] well it's just like I
said it's not his you don't take it
serious like Mardi Gras yeah it's like
everybody's having a good time yeah like
everybody has it has a few drinks it has
a laugh at everybody that embarrassing
themselves and then you just like when I
was a kid having [ __ ] like as a kid
in [ __ ] cotton in Brazil [ __ ]
Carnivale would happen and Carnivale
would [ __ ] trip me the [ __ ] out at
like 16 17 naked women and basically
naked women yeah come everywhere but
it's just you know I mean you get you
build up a tolerance to it's just like
all right that's cool yeah it's just
cool we'll see like I think that's kind
of a problem that we are that arises
with a lot of these kind of people with
these serial killer mentality
mentalities is that they are messed up
and they have
particular fetishes or particular sexual
proclivities and there's nothing wrong
with that but they don't like seem to
find any outlet for expressing that in
any kind of like healthy or
non-destructive way and making a big
deal over nothing thank you because like
I said a lot of times I think that when
you actually and I think that that might
be a reason why
serial killers stuff like tends to
escalate over time is that you they've
built it up in their head so much and
then they actually do it and it wasn't
as cool as they thought it was gonna be
as [ __ ] up and that is to say yeah
that's like well they have to like keep
like making it worse and worse they got
to kill somebody to get laid that's not
[ __ ] lame these [ __ ] are
that yeah that's what I mean like you
know sex and death combined yeah that's
definitely some [ __ ] wires getting
across them this is don't worry
so yes want to kill somebody just to get
laid
yeah it's [ __ ] ridiculous it is I've
beaten [ __ ] ass over some [ __ ]
like that it's just a it's a stupid yeah
right place well yeah like it just seems
like it's not what are you thinking it's
not that big of a deal it's just some of
these dudes I feel like they're they
feel like the entire [ __ ] universe
revolves around they're dead and I just
don't understand I gotta bust a nut so
therefore you got a die right can you
imagine - is that like who the [ __ ] are
you who do you think you alright yeah
that's what I mean it's like I don't
understand this at all but I guess
that's good good I don't understand it
he's just lucky he didn't run across me
you gonna curb stop him I might [ __ ] him
just to teach him a lesson just to make
it it's like some prison [ __ ] like that
you know right now I'm gonna kill you or
what you did that woman you'd probably
be in to predict ulis yeah it is yeah
I'm just talking [ __ ] [ __ ] I mean
these [ __ ] are [ __ ] crazy
making a big deal out of nothing
yeah okay I'm drunk thank you cuz like I
said yeah we get we gotta wrap this bag
out tonight kind of soon so you know
what I mean
yeah well well if you haven't recovered
in time then we can't know I can recover
alright yeah so Mary Nielsen who was
their first victim she was last seen
leaving a shop on Monday October the 6th
she was going to a university lecture
but apparently she never made it there
now her car was found six days after she
disappeared in a parking lot which was
right across the street from police
headquarters apparently David Birney had
parked it there almost like topped the
police or leave a clue I'm not sure if
I'm gonna share why so apparently what
had happened was that Mary had gone to
the burning house like I said she was
going to buy tires and as soon as she
walked in the door
David apparently um like had a knife and
he like put it to her neck and was like
you know you have to do what I say so
like bound and gagged her chained her to
the bed and then David repeatedly raped
her while the wife was watching and the
whole time like the wife is asking him
questions about hey like what what is
turning you on about this the most like
she was like taking notes about the [ __ ]
or something yeah that's what I mean so
she could like later she could like
recreate it I guess you know what I mean
- like for him to get his jollies messed
up it's bad enough when you have like a
just a dude doing this on their own but
when they can get a woman to go along
with this [ __ ] that is like just a hole
it's kind of like immature
it was very immature it's almost it's
almost infantile it is yeah sex is not
that big of a deal yeah I know yeah to
where you're gonna have to [ __ ]
discuss it yeah in that way that's what
I mean these peoples like their whole
[ __ ] lives revolve around oh [ __ ]
yeah so they take the girl out to this
national park called Gleneagles
then David rapes her again they like
take a nylon cord and wrap it around her
neck and then got like a tree branch
like useless like a garage or whatever
and they like strangled her to that then
they stabbed her just for good measure
yeah and then buried her in a shallow
grave
ridiculous yeah two weeks later they
decided they were gonna kill another one
yeah so they kidnapped a 15 year old
girl named Susannah candy she was
hitchhiking in a place called Clermont
that this is Australia like I said she
was obviously still in high school still
lived with her parents now apparently
the Bernese had been like cruising
around just looking for a victim so she
wasn't someone that they had like been
watching ahead of time she was someone
that happened to be on the side of the
road and they said hey let's kill that
one so they stopped to pick her up she
gets in the car he puts a knife to her
throat and tied her all up they took her
back to their house gagged her chained
her to the bed and raped her now this is
[ __ ] up too apparently from what I can
gather from the notes that I have read
about this case so the girl is chained
to the bed David rapes her and then
Katherine gets in the bed and then
Katherine David have sex next to the
chained up girl yeah
so then David tries to strangle the girl
with a cord but she starts freaking out
like as she would and is trying to like
fight him so at this point they forced
sleeping pills down her neck and she
fell asleep and then David says to his
wife hey if you want to prove you love
me you have to strangle her hmm so
Katherine did it apparently without any
problem at all now they asked later on
like after they got caught they asked
Katherine's like well why did you do it
when he told you to and this is what she
said she said because I wanted to see
how strong I was within my inner self
yeah I didn't feel a thing it was like I
expected I was prepared to follow him to
the end of the earth
and do anything to see that his desires
were satisfied she was a female females
hurt and destroy males okay so that's
what she said no special so uh retards
yeah there so they take this poor girl
out to the state forest where they had
buried the other one
buried her right next to it they think
they're so edgy there is nothing it can
be honest it's like edgy about this
should be honest and I think I might
have said this before serial killers are
like the next step of it's like it's
like their extreme edge lords and there
is really nothing I hate yeah trying to
be edgy I mean like I said I just see
them as like a class of edge lords yeah
it's gone like you know what I mean
because they're clearly trying to like
impress people yeah and their parent is
trying to impress themselves too I guess
over [ __ ] nothing you know I mean
you're strangling a person who's already
tied after Witter wears a challenge
there that's not we know they're trying
to equate that with like storming a
Japanese [ __ ] machine gun bunker on
the [ __ ] island of Peleliu you don't
I mean great we're saying one dude yeah
versus seven of them in a damn bunker
with a machine gun you know I got them
all yeah it's like York
you're basically kidnapping a teenage
girl yeah that's smaller than yeah it's
stretch it tighter and then tying her up
so she can't fight back and then you
strangling her I was trying to test my
inner strength [ __ ] please yeah pretty
much that's yeah so November first
uh they see this woman who was 31 years
old her name was no Elaine Patterson now
apparently her car had run out of gas
she was coming home from work in her car
run at a gas so she was like standing
next to the car on the side of the road
so apparently this [ __ ] these [ __ ]
[ __ ] like pull up next to her and
they're like hey you need some help
we'll draw B to a gas station or
whatever and the same [ __ ] deal
happened this woman gets in the car
he holds a knife to her throat and then
they tie her up they take her back to
the house and tot chained her to the bed
and Bernie repeatedly raped her now
apparently in this particular situation
noeleen Patterson was evidently a very
beautiful woman she was like very
elegant she was very like you know
well-liked like a lot of people like
really issues
socially a popular and Catherine Bernie
could not [ __ ] stand her from the
get-go so she because she was like very
jealous and she was seeing how David was
looking at her and it's like it was
really really bothering her a lot so
they were actually see cuz what they
were planning to do just like they had
done before was that they were planning
to bring Nolan home he was gonna rape
her and then they were gonna kill her
just like they had done with the other
two however David was kind of into her
so he like kept putting off killing her
and the more he did that the more angry
that Catherine got and at one point
Catherine got so angry that she put a
knife to her own throat and said if you
don't choose between me and her I'm
gonna stick this [ __ ] knife in my
throat so there was that whole issue so
Nolan was in the house for three days
and then Catherine was finally like look
you need to kill her or I'm gonna kill
myself because you need to pick so they
did the same thing that they did with
the other one they forced an overdose of
sleeping pills down her throat and then
once she was asleep he actually ended up
strangling her while she was asleep they
took her body out to the forest and
buried it next to the other two now
apparently and this is [ __ ] up and
this will kind of come back later but
once before they buried the woman
apparently Catherine like picked up a
whole big handful of dirt and like threw
it in her face that's how mad she was
and like I said this is this is the
thing where she is just as responsible
as [ __ ] he is I'm not saying that it
wasn't like that before but it's like
she is apparently I mean she's just as
into this as him it's not a thing where
she's just going along he's a serial
killer and I'm going along with it these
two are just as [ __ ] up as each other
so only a couple days later on the fifth
of November they kidnapped another girl
21 year-old Denise brown she was waiting
for a bus so apparently she they put her
in the car at knifepoint they take her
back to the house chander to the bedroom
raped her now the next day they took her
to this pine plantation now while she
was in the car
like tied up in the backseat they picked
up another person who was a 19 year old
girl now they tried to but it's like
this girl was like she was walking along
the road I guess she was like looking
for a ride and then she saw like this
car pull up and she saw this couple and
she's like so I look in there and she's
like I thought they were kind of sketchy
cuz like the dude kept looking down and
the woman was like drinking rum and coke
even though I think she was driving and
so she's like so I thought it was a
little weird that they were drinking cuz
it wasn't like nighttime or anything so
um apparently she was just like no it's
okay I'll walk because she thought the
[ __ ] was really sketchy now she did see
the victim in the backseat but she
thought that it was their kid like
sleeping room you know what I mean so
she didn't really she only later on like
when she saw like after they got caught
and she saw like the [ __ ] photographs
of them then she realized oh [ __ ] that
who that was yeah she's like so I don't
know what would have happened had I got
in that car so once they took Denise
Brown into the forest
David raped her again then they took her
out like they he raped her in the car
and then he like dragged her out into
the forest and raped her again and then
he stabbed her in the neck while he was
raping her so that's nice now she
actually didn't die right away now
apparently Katherine was like holding
[ __ ] flashlight on him so he could
work with light on him I guess
and so the victim even though she'd been
stabbed in the throat she starts like
[ __ ] struggling just like trying to
get away and fighting and everything so
apparently Katherine she had a knife too
so she goes over there she's the one
holding the flashlight she goes over
there and [ __ ] was like well stab her
again you know what I mean so she goes
over there hands in the bigger knife and
he's just like [ __ ] stabbed the [ __ ]
out of her and then they dug a shallow
grave and put her in it however before
they finished covering her her up she
was still alive she sat up and then
David took an axe
and hit her in the head with it you and
broke her skull like several times but
she was like [ __ ] trying like hell to
get me the [ __ ] out of there like she
sat up in the [ __ ] grave how [ __ ]
horrible is that and then he just like
hit her in the head with it and that
even that didn't work like he hit her in
the axe one time and she was still like
trying to get out and he had to turn it
around and [ __ ] hit her again damn
holy [ __ ] [ __ ] thankfully she was
probably [ __ ] stunned usually when a
person goes to Majan usually when a
person dies that's an trauma they're not
real all they're kind of robotic I mean
I I would hope that like your brain
would be nice enough to just be like
check out of that [ __ ] because holy crap
these two [ __ ] deserve death yeah you
know yeah no [ __ ]
look how blurry this is getting why is
this no blurry oh maybe maybe yeah it's
it's adjusting to the light I guess
sorry about that so yeah so even though
as I said Katherine Bernie is a piece of
[ __ ] also but apparently the brutality
of this particular murder actually kind
of snapped her out of this [ __ ] like hey
maybe this is a little messed up you
think yeah it was um because apparently
she didn't really care about the women
getting raped and stabbed and strangled
and stuff like that but Oh getting like
smashed in the head with an axe and
stuff like that that was just a little
bit too far you know what I mean so she
apparently decided that she's like well
I I think that this is I have to do
something about this because this is
getting you know to a point where you
know I I don't know if I can do this
anymore
now sometimes speculated that because of
the brutality of the murder of Denise
Brown and the subsequent rethinking of
things that Katherine went through that
this is maybe indirectly how they ended
up getting caught because the next
victim that they kidnapped who was a 16
year old girl who I have not seen named
in the
in the materials that I read so they
kidnapped this girl did the whole thing
where they chained her to the bed David
raped her and stuff like that and they
actually kept her in the house for
several days and Katherine kind of came
to a thing where she didn't deliberately
let the girl go but she knew that David
was going to kill her and that if the
girl escaped and they got caught that it
would be okay so basically what ended up
happening was that you know a couple of
days after this girl had been kidnapped
and she was kind of like you know tied
to the bed and stuff like that the girl
actually ended up getting loose
and because David was at work and I
guess Katherine was supposed to be
watching her but she was kind of like
lacks in it I guess because she was kind
of like low-key maybe over the [ __ ] at
this point so she goes like the doorbell
rings or something like that and she
goes to the door I think it was their
cocaine dealer because the girl that was
kidnapped did say something about David
injecting cocaine into his penis tank
which I'm not sure how good of an idea
that is I've heard of this low down on
the list of legging bad ideas this dude
has had but I'm just saying that I was
like is that a thing I've never heard of
that before I don't think I don't have
experienced myself yeah I mean I don't
know why I'm surprised it's like because
of every every drug every everything has
been injected into everywhere it's been
swallowed it's been stuck up everyone's
ass it's like someone has done it
somewhere [ __ ] but I'm just glad the
girl realizes she had nothing to gain
for me this [ __ ] killing these girls
she's like maybe we should let these
girls go maybe I yeah maybe you should
have thought of that before for [ __ ]
people guys you know I'm just saying at
least she at least came to that but you
know so the girl actually did end up
getting loose and jumping naked out of
the window and running to the police
station
yeah this poor [ __ ] girl she's 16 I
don't blame her I know and she yeah and
she shows up and she tells him all about
she knows where the house is she knows
the address she knows what they look
like she knows everything so she tells
them everything now at this stage it
should be so I mean this is Perth which
is you know
I don't know how big of a town is but
it's not really a city that was known
for being like a haven for serial kids
like that was some big-city [ __ ] that
was like some [ __ ] that haven't Sydney
or something like that it's like it
wasn't really something that happened in
Perth but because these four women had
gone missing in kind of a similar way
and they were kind of from similar
backgrounds so some of the authorities
in Perth had started to suspect that
there was a serial killer on the loose
and so this girl turning up initially
when she turned up they thought it was
Denise Brown because you know she had
most recently been reported missing but
obviously sadly she was already dead at
this point
but this girl turns up and tells him the
story she's like look I know where the
house is you know come on we'll go back
and get it so the cops go to the [ __ ]
house and no one was home at that stage
I think Katherine came home later and
they asked about it she denied
everything and then David came home and
he also denied everything now the thing
about it though was that the girl this
is a [ __ ] smart girl man the victim
she had what she had thought to do she
had taken her bag and her cigarettes and
before she ran she had stuck them up in
the ceiling tile so she could prove that
she had been there you know what I mean
so yes so she had done that and so the
cops went in there and they found the
[ __ ] up there and they said okay well
that's you know she was here just like
she said but the thing was even though
they suspected that these two were
probably responsible for all of these
other women going missing they couldn't
find any other evidence that they had
anything to do with these other
disappearances however because they had
charges sold on the kidnapping of this
one particular girl in the rape of this
particular girl they could at least keep
them and question them and [ __ ] like
that
as I said both of them initially denied
it but at one point one of the
investigators says to David Birney who
can't who had come home like from work
later that day and then they picked him
up as well he was kind of like joking
not thinking anything was gonna come of
it going well it's getting dark better
go get the shovel and dig up all those
people that you killed and David said
okay there's four of them he just said
it like straight out like that and the
cop was like amazed he's like oh my god
I didn't think that was gonna work I was
just kind of like joking
so he led them like out to the [ __ ]
forest where they had buried the four
victims they dug them up and they're
like oh well yeah guess it was you guys
and it's like so once he like had
confessed then they told Katherine you
know you know he's so so she like busted
out and told everything that had
happened as well so they both ended up
getting [ __ ] convicted four counts of
murder several counts of rape kidnapping
etc etc because I believe that area of
Australia does not have the death
penalty actually I don't think I'll
shreya in general has the death penalty
but they got life in prison now one of
them at least I think would have been
eligible for parole in 2007 but they
said because the public the gravity of
the [ __ ] offense because the public
and I saw a documentary about it it's
like when they were taking these two out
of the [ __ ] courtroom it's like there
was like a huge crowd out there they're
just like Strega Bob they were just like
they were very very mad so it's like
they don't think it was kind of like a
Brady and Hindley situation where like
in the UK where yeah it's like even if
technically they're allowed to get
paroled that shit's never gonna happen
because the public just hates them so
[ __ ] much and they're like even now
their house in Perth they're like it has
kind of the same I don't want to say
gravitas because that sounds positive
but it has the same infamy that you know
the house of like you know the the
West's and stuff like that like had in
the UK where it's like people like Drive
I look at it it's like that's where
there's [ __ ] that's where the
Bernese lived and [ __ ] like that um you
will be happy to hear that David Birney
like was beat up many times in prison
and also that he is suicide that's not a
manly crime
you got a prison over some [ __ ] like
that and everybody knows we that's what
I mean it's like what you know it's
obviously killing anybody's not good um
you know it killing innocent people of
any of any kind is not good yeah but
it's like a dude that you know just kind
of kidnapped like poor defenseless like
teenagers that are just like walking us
or waiting for a bus or whatever just to
like tie them up rate them murder them
it's like you know prisoners that don't
fly also have wives and daughters
innings
be worried about all their family
members on the outside if you want to go
to prison you got a prison under the
[ __ ] charge of bank robbery yeah
killing an enemy [ __ ] like that
that's a man's crime that's what I mean
it's like yes so in a way I can't feel
too bad about other prisoners even like
being like nah bro right and just like
beating the crap out of you because it's
like I'm not saying what they did was so
much better they'd be in there but it's
like doing [ __ ] like that that you you
[ __ ] deserve getting your [ __ ] ass
beat for that kind of [ __ ]
well some prisoners are in there for
handling their business that's what they
call it on the street handling their
business yeah my take my hair is
somebody who [ __ ] em oh I can see that
it's like I don't street justice that's
what I mean I know it's terrible but
it's like you know if the person that
you're killing is also a terrible person
yeah but I didn't feel quite as bad
about it yeah most the time it is like I
said you you know but just like killing
like a 15 year old girl that was just
waiting for a [ __ ] bus I mean
obviously that is not forgivable in any
yeah and it's like what the and the fact
that he got a woman his wife yeah well
technically not his wife because that
was another that was another thing when
they were in prison like because the
judge was like you know separate these
[ __ ] don't let them ever see each
other ever again and they were
apparently really upset by that because
they wanted to like marry for real and
it's like they wanted to see each other
and stuff the judges like no that is not
happening um and they were kind of like
trying to petition it's like oh it's not
fair and yadi I was like yeah well
life's not fair so there was that whole
thing going on too so they were not
allowed to marry they were not allowed
to see each other they were not allowed
anything like I said they never got
parole or anything and rightfully so
because these two were [ __ ] [ __ ]
and like I said this is even a case
maybe even worse than um well I don't
want to say worse than Brady and Hindley
but in in that sense I think Brady was
the worse of the two like I don't think
that Myra Hindley would have done
anything had she not met him these two
I'm not really sure because Katharine
kind of seemed like a piece of [ __ ] from
the beginning to um I don't compare any
of these cases [ __ ] it's hard to you
can't just put him in
the shitpile mm-hmm you know that's what
I do like these people are [ __ ] yeah
and these two I mean like the BTK is a
[ __ ] BTK sitting right here and you're
talking [ __ ] to his face - you're not
the mood - yeah
BTK sounds kind of drunk yeah drugs a
doobie GK I gotta sober up soon go out
tonight I know right yeah it's getting
to a point where I need a drive I need
to start thinking about getting right
it's still like several hours before we
go but I still have to like think about
yeah trying to get ready and stuff like
I only had like five drinks wait five
well uh - but you know I pour oh well -
but so it was like - no there's Tom Ross
pours yeah yeah very heavy here you
would get fired being a bartender
because like given to given technique is
like liquor away
I don't know Tom you know his bar he
told me that [ __ ] per bodily doesn't
pay much yeah I'm pretty yeah pretty
healthy like yeah margin right cuz you
can get a bottle for pretty cheap and
you can get like a lot of you just
telling me the price of Bali's that dude
man of bottles only [ __ ] $5 I was
like what
well wholesale yeah well no he's getting
them for the through the liquor dealers
yeah you know I mean a civilian or a
regular person pay $12 for a [ __ ]
fish even if you paid $1 I mean you're
still getting like several like $10
cocktails out of that right well he's
paying five instead of twelve yeah so
the profit margin is big what you're
paying for the ambience or something
yeah cuz you know you can drink much
cheaper at home yeah but you know well
you can drink cheaper at home but bar
price what they're paying for a [ __ ]
fifth is [ __ ] nothing
yeah yeah well like I said you do that
really cheap [ __ ] low low [ __ ]
rotgut bottom of the shelf [ __ ] vodka
that if I can you see it [ __ ] like
aristocrat yeah I think it's called
aristocrats like a dollar fifth that's
more than it's worth
yeah
the thing about it and like look I'm not
a liquor stop it's like I'll drink um
you know [ __ ] what's that [ __ ]
whipped cream vodka
I'll drink pinnacle that's good that's
only like eleven twelve dollars probably
a pretty big bottle of it but even
aristocrat regrets [ __ ] that's a
little too I mean that's basically just
like drinking like rubbing out yeah it's
hard to mess up vodka but that's cuz
vodka is like all in what you mix it
with and stuff but that just tastes like
kerosene yes it tastes like you're
drinking kerosene but the nice thing
about vodka not only can you mix it with
a lot of different things because it
doesn't have like a real strong flavor
of its own so it's very versatile which
I like about it but it's you don't have
to get like a super expensive one to
have like a decent drink with it I mean
like I said you can get like a $12 thing
a pinnacle and it tastes perfectly fine
if you're the cheapest decent tasting
vodka I've found a Skye
well Skye is a little bit more expensive
than pinnacle by a dollar or two the
thing is is we're talking about
unflavored vodkas yeah it's easier to
get away with a flavored vodka yes guys
and unflavored vodka that's what I'm
drinking right now yeah yes it is this
guy in here right now is a civilian
price first guys about what $12 a fifth
well now that I usually get like the
1.75 liter one which i think is 22 or 23
what did I say you said $1.00 a fifth a
fifth I think I thought yeah well that's
what I paid for it it might have been
less weird you did where'd you get at
the Walmart liquor store Publix oh you
got it at Publix that looks like our
story okay maybe that was $20 so you
think you might is $19 for that big yeah
I think I think well I got it at the
Walmart liquor store like last time like
a few months ago when I bought one I got
like a big one which is 1.75 liters
about 20 bucks and I think it was 1999
or 2190 ever and the thing is is that's
actually a good taste of vodka
now the Salmons won you get a 1.75 liter
yeah
for $13.99 I think the last time I
bought it I think it was $13.99 and
Sam's and that's decent
Sam's Silver Tequila
tastes every bit like Milagro yeah
silver and they are they're only $19
yeah so if you have a Sam's Club or you
know Sam's membership yeah go to the Sam
flickers don't get the whiskey though
cuz that's not a so she's terrible but
um everything rockin it to keep the
vodka is good the tequila's groms good
the rums good yeah and it's like way
cheaper yeah than a comparable tasting
it is I mean from what I've you know
like I said I'm not a licker snap I
don't know I keep going back to that
damn Sam's tacky Silver Tequila I mean
that's just like Milagro silver for a
fraction of the price it is yeah and
like I said if you know we don't always
go to the same because the Publix is a
lot closer
um so usually if we don't want to drive
all the way to Sam's liquor store cuz
that's kind of like a lot farther but um
I say a lot farther it's like all we do
is talk about crime paranormal [ __ ]
sex and booze well have what had this
should happen well that's our that's for
gold topics Dean that's more than some
people talk about some people only talk
about one topic ever yeah we're we're
well-rounded I guess and those are all
very interesting topics that people want
to know about yourself sex and booze
particularly right now we've got to go
out tonight
oh we do yeah yeah and it's almost time
for me to start go getting ready getting
pretty to go out cuz that takes me like
a really long time I'm gonna sleep some
of this you know yeah you really need to
because I mean you still have said you
saw have a few hours you're alright I
can just go true I just gotta wear it
off it's gonna be a little wear off yeah
yeah you'll be alright yeah I'm drunk
that much just don't worry about nothing
alright so hope you guys like I said
it's enjoyed our truncated Valentine's
Day show which I which I thought was
gonna be like about much more cases but
no hopefully we got into enough of it
it's a special twos enough yeah um
anyway so like I said Valentine's Day is
this week this is gonna be out a few
days before we're also gonna do like
other Valentine's themed shows like
movie review and the witching hour show
is kind of gonna be Valentine's themed
as well so hope you guys enjoy that and
have a good Valentine's Day and
everything like that remember if you
liked the show like share subscribe and
all your social media be sure to check
out our new Instagram I promise I will
put more stuff up there because there's
only like four I live right now
instagram so follow us on Instagram we
just [ __ ] started it like I said like
a decade too late but whatever we're
finally getting into it we're too old
yeah what's your bold for the social
media should have time to keep up with
all this crap but yeah so remember if
you want to support the show you can go
to our patreon page patreon.com/lenguin
to a PayPal account if you'd like to
able one-time donation anything would be
much appreciated and helps to make the
show better and I hope that you guys
have enjoyed episode 182 our third
valentine's day special we will see you
next time bye
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you
[Music]